chosen
[Music]
oh
the house will come to order members
[Music]
here
the house will come to order
the chair recognizes the member from
auburn representative osborne who moves
the house adjourned from the session to
march 15 2022. are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it and
the house is adjourned
the house will attend to a prayer by
house chaplain reverend bob stewart
pastor of saint paul's united methodist
good morning let us be in a spirit of
prayer
in the middle of this week oh god
assure us again of your presence in the
midst of our lives
renew our strength and determination to
do your will here on earth
even as it is done in heaven above
guard and protect us from experiencing a
sense of self
contentment
and from having a vision that may be too
narrow
enable us to reach outside this chamber
into our communities
and even stretch us further beyond our
communities
may we somehow become
your agents
of change
may those changes be for the good of all
people here in new hampshire
and even some corner of this anguished
world
we again come to you in prayer today
with hopes that through our collective
and unified prayers we might see an end
to the war
against ukraine
we also ask for prayers for the russian
people
who are caught in the middle of this war
oh god you created and breathed life
into all of humanity
every life is precious to you and in
turn every life should be precious
to each of us as well
oh god of love and peace i pray you will
be with each member of this house
and i pray that you keep your guiding
and watchful hand upon each of them
guide them and help them to make sound
decisions for the people they represent
and to make sound decisions for the
state of new hampshire
i pray that your guiding hand upon each
member
will give them the courage and strength
to guide their hearts
in doing what is right and just for all
people
keep them all safe and healthy o god
and free of any harm
we also ask that you be with all the
leadership of the house
keep your hands upon them
as they lead this body
o god of the alpha and the omega
may we be your hands and feet in this
world
and again
we ask that you keep
help us to be your agents of change
it is in your glory and honor we pray
the chair recognizes the member of
portsmouth the dean of the house
representative laura panalakis will lead
the chair recognizes the member from
marlborough who said lucius parcell who
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks
house will attend
mr speaker the day illness
representatives birch cleaver ellis mary
griffin hopper jack kimball lawton
littlefield
lundgren milor newton salloway
safiquitas tudor vale
the day important business
representatives cody crawford harvey
the day illness in the family
these leaves of absence shall be granted
unless otherwise ordered by the house
the house will attend
mr speaker please welcome for
i don't believe they're in the gallery
welcome to the new hampshire house
house will now attend
the house will now attend a continuation
of the regular calendar beginning with
house bill 1332
foreign
so
can i have everyone's attention for a
minute
we have a
slight malfunction i.t is on its way up
so we'll be
in a short recess until we can get this
so
i would start over from the beginning mr
speaker
tiffany
the majority of the committee on
education to which was referred house
bill 1332
an act accepting public universities and
colleges from requirements under medical
freedom and organizations have been
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate present of
glenn cordelli from the majority of the
committee minority of the committee have
been considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass senator linda tanner from the
minority of the committee
jericho
for what reason does a member rise good
morning mr speaker i rise to make a
motion stage of motion to table 1332
it is a proper motion the motion before
us
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1332
this will be a division vote members
take your seats roll call who requested
a roll call
representative cushman requested a roll
calls that's officially seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
ricky's
the motion before us is to lay house
bill 1332 on the table this is a roll
call vote
the chair recognizes representative luna
thank you mr speaker
if i know parents expect public and
private colleges to take reasonable
steps to protect the health and safety
of students
and if i know i want to hear the debate
on how this bill will better enable
public colleges to protect our kids who
go there make new hampshire's colleges
more attractive build our workforce and
grow our economy than would i press the
red button to defeat the tabling motion
geo recognizes representative lang for a
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker mr speaker if i know that every
citizen has a natural essential and
inherent right to bodily integrity and
free from threat or compulsion by
government to accept an immunization and
we have affirmed that right
just last year at the passes of hb 220
the underlying law that this bill seeks
to amend
mr speaker if i further know that this
bill seeks to make a subclass of new
hampshire citizens where that natural
essential inherent right would be taken
away
and mr speaker lastly if i want to
protect all new hampshire citizens
reaffirm that natural essential and
inherent right to bodily integrity free
from threat or compulsion from
government would i now press the green
button and support the tabling motion
they ain't going to work if you don't
the motion before us is to lay house
bill 1132 on the table this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
vault members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
172 voting yeah 142 voting a house bill
majority of the committee on education
to which was referred house bill 1355
an act requiring scholarship
organization to refer suspected cases of
misuse of funds or fraud in the
education freedom account program the
attorney general having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolve that has been
expedient to legislate present of glenn
cordelli from the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being able to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass senator david luno from the
for what reason does a member i rise to
make a motion stage of motion to table
1355.
it is a proper motion
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1355
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
the eyes the eyes have it house bill
majority committee on education to which
was referred house bill 1367
an act relative to
civic extraction instruction in schools
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with amendment president of glen
cordelli for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
linda tanner for the minority of the
committee
the amendment is zero nine three three h
are you this the question is on the
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted the question before us now
is on the committee report of ought to
pass with amendment are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it the committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on education
to which was refused referred house bill
act relative to participation in the
education freedom accounts program by
students with disabilities having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution that resolved
it is inexpedient to legislate groups in
of deborah hobson for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment senator patricia
cornell from the minority of the
committee
what reason does the members to make a
motion stage of motion to table 1376.
it is a proper motion this motion before
us is a table house bill 1376
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1376 this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know
that informing parents about the rights
of their special ed students should be a
priority for all of us and if i know
that the department of education
contributed to the drafting of this bill
would i now push the red button against
the tabling motion so that the debate
could continue
thank you
chair recognizes representative hobson
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that in committee we learned all these
provisions in this bill are already in
rule and if i know we have many bills to
get through this week would i now press
the motion before us is the table house
bill
1376 this is a roll call vote you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
this
all members president and opportunity
[Music]
if all members president had an
house will attend to the state of the
vote
179 voting 853 voting a
committee on education to which was
referred house bill 1381 an act relative
to student school board members
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation the bill ought to
pass senator alicia leakes for the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
this is going to be a roll call vote we
have no debate we just have pis
representative notter has requested a
it is sufficiently seconded members will
that's right majority committee on
education to which is referred house
bill 1434 fn an act relative to the
availability of school curriculum
materials having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment the recommendation that the
bill are to pass with amendment
president rick ladd for the majority of
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
fallen resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislative
representative sue mullen from the
minority of the committee
the amendment is zero nine nine two h
printed in house record 10 a page 58.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it the
amendment is adopted and the motion
before us now is out to pass with
amendment
on house bill 1434.
this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative mullin
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that provisions already exist under
rsa 186 colon 11 for parents and
guardians to review curriculum materials
in a timely fashion
and request alternatives
and if i know
without any demonstrated need that this
bill would extend the opportunity beyond
parents and guardians to any resident in
a community
and require unspecified staff to gather
indeterminable amounts of course
materials within a 10-day window
and if i believe that the policies and
procedures already in law are adequate
enough to address any concerns would i
now oppose the recommendation of ought
to pass as amended by pushing the red
button so that another motion may be
made
the chair recognizes representative
sanborn for a parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker if i know that parents
taxpayers and residents have a natural
right to know what is being taught in
their schools
and if i know that this bill simply
honors this right and requires
curriculum materials to be made
available within 10 days of the request
would i then now support new hampshire
parents and ensure transparency and
public education by pressing the green
button
the motion before us is the majority
report of what to pass as amended on
house bill one four three four this is a
roll call vote you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you oppose you
press the red button voting stations are
so
[Music]
while my mr president had an opportunity
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
185 volnigne 152 vonnie
majority of committee on education to
which was referred house bill 1564 fn
local an act requiring school districts
to provide breakfast for students have
been considered the same report the same
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate senator
deborah hopson for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass senate arthur ellison from the
chair recognizes representative ellison
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i rise in opposition to the
itl motion on hp 1564.
there is no disagreement that students
who participate in breakfast programs
have better school attendance and higher
academic performance than those who are
hungry
all of the research on this issue
supports those conclusions
the committee heard comments during the
hearing on this bill that if students
came to school hungry is the fault of
the parents
this perspective does not reflect the
reality of some students lives some of
whom are homeless
others who are living in dysfunctional
family situations
and it is not fair to blame the actions
or in this case
the inactions of parents on their
children
feeding our children should be one of
the highest priorities of our schools in
this case the 30 school districts that
do not currently provide breakfast to
their students
and finally it's a sad commentary on our
priorities when we need legislation in
order to feed children
but that's where we are now
thank you mr speaker
i recognize the representative hobson to
thank you mr speaker in the education
hearings we learned that of
466 schools taking advantage of the
school lunch program
only 30 were not already providing
breakfast if this if this measure were
to pass schools would need to expand
offerings to comply with the provisions
of this bill likely increasing costs at
an amount indeterminable
some of the costs to the department of
education are startup
costs to start up the program and
personnel to oversee and run the program
these functions are currently not funded
and as a result would violate the new
hampshire constitution article 28a as an
unfunded mandate with only 30 schools in
new hampshire not participating in the
program it would seem to be a matter of
choice over costs for these reasons i
would request you support the itl motion
the question before us is the itl motion
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested members
will take their seats this will be a
clear
the motion before us
is the majority report of any speed to
legislate on house bill 1564.
this is a division vote the chair
recognizes representative woodcock for
if i know that new hampshire currently
ranks 47th out of the 50 states
in our nation's school lunch
participation
and each day new hampshire misses
serving 7
869 students school breakfast
and annually leaves on the floor of the
table 1.5 million dollars of food
federal funding money
and if i know research supports that
student from food insecure and mildly
secure households get more of their food
nutrients from school middle school
meals than any other student and if i
know the research data that supports
students who have more nutritious diets
tend to perform better and pay more
attention in school
and finally if i know this bill was
wisely sponsored and co-sponsored by
several republican representatives then
we should file their lead and vote no on
the itl so a more food-filled option can
chair recognizes representative ford for
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this bill changes school
requirements from providing students one
meal a day
to mandating that they provide both
breakfast and lunch
and if i know that this would apply only
to the 30 districts that do not
currently provide breakfast
and if i know this is a 28a issue that
will cost thousands of dollars for those
30 districts
would i now itl this unfunded mandate by
thank you speaker the motion before us
is the majority report of any speed is a
legislator on house bill one five six
four this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
so
mr speaker
while members president had an
opportunity to vote
under an 80 voting a 160 voting a
majority of committee on education to
which was referred house bill 1576 fn
not repealing the law relative to
certain discrimination in public
workplaces in education
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate senator rick
ladd for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the recommendations the bill ought
to pass senate sue mullen for the
for what reason does a member rise thank
you mr speaker i rise to make a motion
stage of motion to table 1576.
[Music]
the motion before us is to table house
house bill 1576 a roll call has been
requested as that's officially seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us is to table
house bill 1576
this will be a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that the
prohibition against teaching
discrimination in public workspaces is
about censoring public employers and
programs from sharing historical
information that questions the status
quo
and if i know that our country was
founded on the principle that speaking
without fear of reprisal is essential
and guaranteed
and if i believe that we have a
responsibility to defend the first
amendment would i now press the red
button to oppose the tabling motion so
that another motion could be made thank
you
i recognize the representative ladd for
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker if i know that discrimination of
any kind is unacceptable in public
workplaces and education now if i also
know the new hampshire department of
education has launched launched a new
web page in support new hampshire
commission of human rights aimed to
ensure that students and educators are
free from discrimination and that they
have the opportunity to learn and teach
in a safe environment and lastly if i
believe this new law provides a unique
opportunity for the department
and all school districts to have a
meaningful conversations about
discrimination and to better understand
and differentiate between discrimination
and non-discrimination would i then
support the tabling motion by pressing
the green button
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1576 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're imposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
representative spang
you have to give me a thumb up or a
thumb down
while members president had an
opportunity to vote
186 voting yay 158 voting a committee
report that lane house bill 1576 is laid
members stay in your seats this is going
to be another quick one
majority the committee on education to
which was referred house bill 1607 fn
an act prohibiting unlawful
discrimination in public and non-public
schools having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate
senator glenn cordelli for the majority
of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same maybe an honorable
degree with the majority report with the
following amendment and the
recommendations the bill ought to pass
with amendment representative linda
tanner from the minority of the
committee
for what reason is a member rise i rise
to make a motion stage motion to table
proper motion
representative tanner has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
so
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1607
this is going to be a roll call vote the
chair recognizes representative tanner
if i know there we go
if i know that hb 1607
extends the new hampshire
non-discrimination law
and equal protection to all schools
tuition programs and educational
services receiving state funding
and if i know that the state board of
education should have the responsibility
to ensure that all students in new
hampshire
in protected classes as defined in new
hampshire law
are shielded from discrimination
and if i know that public funding
requires public accountability and
that's why we need to hear this debate
would you please vote against the
the chair recognizes from senator
cordelli for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that we
are making progress getting through the
calendar today
if i know that the director of the human
rights commission testified in our
committee that this bill would
complicate and delay discrimination
complaints processing and investigations
and if i know that this bill would
effectively remove the constitutionally
protected exemptions for religious
organizations
would i now vote to get on with our
business so that we don't have to stay
here until 4 a.m on friday by pressing
the motion before us is the table house
bill
1607.
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
remember
[Music]
we're in the voting mode number stay in
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
we thought you were out
thumbs up or thumbs down representative
awesome
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
189 voting yay 155 voting a
majority committee on education to which
was referred house bill 1632 fn act
relative to civil rights education in
public and elementary and secondary
schools
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill
be referred for interim study
presenter of alicia leak is for the
majority of the committee minority of
the committee having considered the same
would be an unable to agree with the
majority report with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpedient
to legislate senator linda tanner for
reason does the memorize
i rise to make a motion stage of motion
to table this bill 1632
is a proper motion the motion before us
is the table
house bill
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it in 1632 is laid on the
table
the jury the committee on education to
which was referred house bill 1638
an act relative to grievances under the
right to freedom from discrimination in
public workplaces in education
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate
president alicia leake is for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same would be an unable
to agree with the majority report with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass
president of linda tanner from the
what reason does a member i rise to make
the motion before us is the table 1638
rep
representative luno has requested roll
calls that's officially seconded it is
sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1638
chair recognizes representative tanner
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this bill will bring a
local procedure
for discrimination claims in schools
and if i know that this bill provides a
way to bring local solutions and local
remedies for discrimination claims that
will help bring civility and respect
rather than division to our schools
and uh if i know i am here today to do
my job to sit and listen to debates
and to allow a debate like this on a
very important issue
would i press the red button
so that we can have the debate we're
the chair recognizes representative
alicia leakes for parliamentarian gray
thank you mr speaker
if i know that once again this
repeals
language
protecting people protecting our
students from discrimination
and if i know
that this bill mandates
that the parents first go to the
superintendent
and if the superintendent is the one
that is initiating the discrimination
the parent has nobody to go to and will
be afraid to go
because they will be afraid of
recrimination against their
children
would i then
press the green button
the motion before us is a table house
bill 1638
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
hmm
all members president an opportunity to
vote
190 voting a 152 voting nay house bill
the majority committee on education to
which was referred house bill 1639
act relative to youth risk behavioral
survey in schools having considered the
same report the same with the following
amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with amendment
senator ralph bohm for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate
senator sue mullen for the minority of
the committee
the amendment is zero one eight nine h
printed in house record 10a pages 82.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
i suppose nay
guys have it and the amendment is
adopted the motion before us is majority
report of octopass as amended the chair
recognizes
representative mullen speak against the
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i rise in opposition to the
house ed majority recommendation of
ought to pass as amended to house bill
relative to the youth risk behavior
survey
the yrbs has been used as an instrument
to capture student voices since 1993.
for 29 years it has provided
confidential data regarding student at
risk behaviors
to schools law enforcement and community
agencies so that they may develop and
deliver programs that speak directly to
student needs
currently any parent who does not wish
for their child to participate in the
yrbs
only needs to notify the school and the
child will be exempted
that is detailed under rsa 186 11 along
with the requirements for parental
notification and the required
opportunity to review the document
house bill 1639
seeks to flip the process and require
that any parent who wishes their child
to particip participate provides written
permission
on the surface this may seem like no big
deal
but the reality is that anyone who has
ever had to collect permission slips
knows
that even for high interest activities
like field trips films and sporting
events
hectic lives and forget forgetful
children often result in paperwork being
left on the kitchen counter
without a permission slip there would be
no participation
the impact of inadequate participation
those most affected had a lot to say
house education received impassioned
testimony from many stakeholders
the national alliance on mental illness
the coalition against domestic and
sexual violence
new futures the franklin new hampshire
chief of police the raymond coalition
for youth the strafford county substance
misuse prevention coordinator
and our own state of new hampshire
public health services director pointed
out that the data collected by this
survey
allows them to secure funding and
address topics such as bullying
suicide prevention
substance misuse
violence harassment vaping anxiety
depression and more
to a person they pointed out the
benefits to communities from the
targeted responses that guide them in
knowing what individual communities need
and to a person they talked about the
potentially devastating impact of not
being able to survey the minimum number
of students required for the data to be
considered representative
excuse me
and unbiased
their programs and services are at risk
of elimination
you may hear testimony today the kids
don't take this survey seriously
and that may be true for a few
you may hear that the
is considered a joke by some
again possible
but what about the kids that do take it
seriously
how many kids have we helped maybe even
saved because we listened to them
instruments like the yrbs have metrics
built into them to account for the
responses that are obviously untrue
the outliers get tossed so that the
results are reliable and not skewed
there is nothing funny about drug and
alcohol abuse or suicide
there's no joke in sexual violence
anxiety and depression or being the
victim of bullying
there are tough issues addressed in the
youth risk behavior survey without a
doubt because these are the real issues
that are challenging our
kids we heard testimony from experts in
the field that when participation moves
from opt-out to opt-in
data and requirements are affected
and programs are eliminated
questions remain
if not the tried and true yrbs how will
we go about gathering the data to know
what we should be doing
do we guess
are we going to be required to shift the
expenses for current programs onto our
constituents
what kind of messages are we delivering
to our youth when we silence their
voices because the topics are too tough
to talk about
for these reasons i ask that you press
the red button against the ought to pass
as amended recommendation so that
another motion may be made
thank you
we're down to the last speaker
representative mullen has requested a
roll call
is that sufficiently seconded
it is officially seconded this is going
to be a roll call vote members take your
seats
thank you mr speaker
some years ago i introduced a bill to
put a rein in on non-academic surveys
parents had to be notified and questions
provided
bill finally passed and is now law even
though there have been multiple tries to
change it
everything was opt
out except for the youth risk
behavior survey
however
this survey is taken as a joke by most
high school students when i was on the
school board this was given in our high
school i heard from students that they
were taking this as a class project to
see how bad they can make it
how many times do we get drunk
do you take drugs and then they asked
answered on how to do it
some weeks later our principal came to
our high school school board meeting
with the disastrous results
i then informed them how the survey was
taken
our student school board member verified
this other schools have the same issues
when they know the survey is being taken
social media goes rampant
but entries on how to answer the
questions
we had testimony with this as testimony
at our
hearing also parents need to know what
their children are being asked
parental rights all questions on any
survey must be given to parents so they
can make the decision to allow their
children to take the survey over the
years we've heard arguments that parents
do not get the permission slip for the
survey so they do not opt in interesting
parents have to opt in for field trips
they seem to be returned
parents don't opt in because they do not
want the child to take it and nowadays
this is also being done electronically
emails etc to parents so it's not hidden
in the school bag
some now some may testify that the
survey and others are all academic it is
a school's responsibility to teach not
be social workers
these only these surveys only interfere
with the student learning activities for
example in the cte committee that i'm on
it came out that some career tech
education students may miss their
courses because the surveys be taken at
their resident school
and it's been proven time after time
that no survey is anonymous
the first seven questions on this survey
one can easily determine who is
answering the questions age grades grade
sex race height weight etc
then there are questions on using drugs
anyone guess who will answer correctly
if they are
and questions on drugs drinking sex
suicide can also serve as training aids
we've seen this in the past with some
drug programs and why they have been
stopped
parents need to know again what
questions are being asked for their
children
if their parents are specifically asked
to opt in then they will take the
opportunity to check the questions and
at what percentage point does it make
the seri the survey immaterial
if only some are answering correctly
remember this survey is done by the cdc
and depending on what administration is
in power questions do become political
in the past there are questions on guns
at home
now i bet this year there'll be
questions and vaccinations
another argument
is that they need the entire school to
take the survey to get the full results
what's the
difference students answering as a joke
or not answering at all
so please press the green button thank
you
the motion before us
is the majority report of what to pass
as amended this is a roll call vote
so
chair recognizes representative cornell
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that i have no idea
how to counter the amount of
misinformation you have just been given
and if i know that numerous stakeholders
testified that they relied on the data
collected by the youth behavior survey
to plan programs and services to address
bullying suicide anxiety substance abuse
and more
and if i know that surveys and tests
have built-in metrics to account for the
very small number of students that may
not take it seriously and if i know that
i was in a school when students were
taking this risk survey and i don't know
of very many at all that said oh i'm
just going to make a joke out of this
and if i know that after spending 36
years in education
that opt-in does not work
even for a great field trip because kids
are forgetful and if i know that i spent
hours in the morning before a field trip
calling parents for their crying child
to please run in with that permission
slip
would i now vote no and press the red
for future
parliamentary inquiries and for future
speeches
i'm going to ask that all the members
adhere to what we
try
and observe in this chamber that we do
not try
and put
blame or suggest that somebody else has
a bad motive or of anything of that
nature so please
please i'm talking to both
for what reason does a member rise
for an inquiry of the chair
you may inquire
mr speaker isn't there a difference
between
maligning and questioning motive
and what i heard
which was a concern
about
facts
the member in my opinion suggested that
now
i i
am addressing both sides of the aisle
here
we've had it before we've had it
yesterday
and it's already started today
and i'm asking all the members
to refrain from making any type of an
you may further inquire
thank you mr speaker and i i
appreciate the explanation and agree
with it entirely
my concern is that there is a difference
between the word
misinformation
which simply means a mistake and
disinformation which implies a lie thank
you
the chair recognizes representative
alicia leakers for a parliamentary
inquiry
uh before you start representative
yesterday we i asked also that we keep
our
parliamentary inquiries to parliamentary
inquiries
they're starting to get a little bit
long i'm not referring to you right now
representative but they're starting to
get a little bit long on both sides of
the aisle
so please
keep your parliamentary inquiries to
what they should be a true parliamentary
thank you mr speaker if i know
that false information
can lead to false results and we're
based in
and then we would be basing actions on
false results
and if i know
that
many parents object to this survey
and if i know
that
some that most school district websites
are so large and so complicated then
even if notification is given on the
website the parents may well not find it
and even know to be able to opt out what
i now press green thank
you the motion before us is the majority
report about to pass as amended on house
bill 1639
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
183 voting yay 164 voting a
for what reason does november rise um
just i'd like to request the remarks
from the prior debate be printed in the
okay everybody calm down
the motion was made to have the remarks
printed in the permanent journal from
okay
first first of all when any
the house will be in order
first of all
any questions points of order
will the member has to come down to the
podium
unlike the last two years where an off
campus from now on the member must come
down to the podium and ask the question
and to answer
it is part of the remarks and yes it
would be included in the permanent
journal
a division has been requested
too seats
so
[Music]
the motion before us is to print the
remarks in the permanent journal from
the prior debate
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
so
representative
all members president had an opportunity
house will attend to the state of the
vote
240 vote eda 106 voting nay remarks will
so
but it's got to reset the system
we're gonna
we're gonna take a quick recess we still
got some i.t issues going on so we're
theresa
teresa
the house will be you know
the house the house will be in order
recognize the clerk
mr speaker in a letter from the chair of
the criminal justice committee pursuant
to house rule 47 f as chair of house
criminal justice i hereby wave off the
second committee assignment of house
majority committee on education to which
was referred house bill 1669 fn an act
requiring the department of education to
administer the education freedom account
program having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate senator michael moffatt
from the majority of the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass senator stephen woodcock for the
chair recognizes representative ladd
thank you very much mr speaker i rise to
make a motion state your motion to table
1669.
is the proper motion the motion
is to table one six six nine
representative luna has requested a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
up
the motion before us is to table house
bill 1669
the chair recognizes representative luno
thank you mr speaker
if i know new hampshire's 160 000 public
school kids perform among the best in
the country and that's what parents want
and if i know this bill would have the
department of education manage
the
state's voucher program returning
millions of dollars every year to
education
and if i know that i want to hear the
debate on how this bill would actually
increase voucher funds by 10 percent
instead of it being pocketed by a
contractor with current and former state
reps on their board then would i press
the red button so that we can hear the
debate on this bill thank you
chair recognizes representative moffatt
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that abraham lincoln
that guy
if
if i know that
him lincoln was
was correct when he advised
against changing horses in the middle of
a stream
and
if i know that the education freedom
account program is in its infancy
and it's way too soon way too early to
pass judgment regarding current program
administrative structure and finally
if i know that the department of
education does not seek
and is not prepared to suddenly
take over the efa program administration
then would i press the shiny dartmouth
big green button to support the tabling
resolution thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1669 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you press
the red button voting stations are open
so
hmm
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
under an 85 voting yeah 158 voting a
house bill
of the committee on education to which
was referred house bill 1670 local and
act relative to funds of the education
freedom account program after
termination of a student's participation
responsibilities of the scholarship
organization having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate senator debra hobson for
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass presenter david luno for
what reason does a member rise i rise to
make a motion state your motion
the motion before us is to table house
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested
we have no parliamentary inquiries so it
so
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1670
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you opposed you'll press the red button
so
representative
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
188 voting yeah 163 voting nay house
majority of the committee on education
to which was referred house bill
1672 an act relative to misuse of
education freedom account funds having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate senator
felicia leake is for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same would be an
nw degree with the majority report with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass senator david luno from the
the motion before us is the inexpedient
to legislate on house bill 1672 why are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted
majority of the committee on education
to which was referred 1683 fn local
an act repealing the education freedom
account program having considered the
same report the same with the fallen
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate representative glenn
cordelli for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and be an edible
degree with the majority report with a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative david luno for the
minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative porter
thank you mr mr speaker and good morning
again colleagues
i have a few definitions here for you
this morning
according to ed choice
and i think most of you know who ed
choice is it's not a man
school vouchers
give parents the freedom to choose a
private school for their children
using all or part of the public funding
set aside for their children's education
according to
britannica pro con this is the site the
encyclopedia britannica puts up
issuing
debating pros and cons of various issues
britannica pro khan says
school vouchers
are state or school district-funded
scholarships
that allow students to attend a private
school
of the family's choice
and according to ed choice
18 states and d.c
had one or more voucher programs
arkansas florida georgia indiana
louisiana maine maryland mississippi new
hampshire
north carolina ohio oklahoma tennessee
utah vermont and wisconsin
and according to the cambridge
dictionary
a school voucher in the u.s
is a scholarship
that allows a student to attend a
private school rather than a public
school
in the words of the bard
new hampshire
now has the most expansive school
the house will be in order and yet this
body has never had a chance to listen to
a debate
and vote on the provisions of the bill
which established it
hb 20 the house version of the program
raised so many concerns
it was retained in committee for further
work
but the senate rushed ahead anyway
and included their similarly flawed
version of in hb2
we have been told that bills attempting
to fix this myriad of ills and we've
heard many of them today this week
are a cruel attempt
at death by a thousand cuts
and that those proposing such bills were
members of the education establishment
cared nothing for the poor
or the harm done for children
despite the fact that most of us
have spent our entire working career
it's 40 years for me
i have working lives loving and teaching
them
so this is what we have
a program that is wildly unpopular with
the general public
a program that lacks accountability
administered by an out-of-state company
which gets to decide
who is approved who gets funded and what
qualifies as an educational expense
with lacks rules passed over the
objections of the professionals
responsible for advising us
on rulemaking
a program that allows organizations
receiving public funds to discriminate
against those they don't approve of
a program that may leave students and
taxpayers susceptible to fraud and abuse
a program that could leave the state dry
financially because there are no budget
caps
no limits on how much can be spent
in just the first few months
it's already nearly nine million dollars
over budget
and growing
the lba has warned us
that if all eligible students not
currently enrolled in public schools not
enrolled in public schools
took advantage of the program the cost
to the state could be 70 million dollars
a year i'm going to say that again these
are for all the kids out there that are
eligible for this program now
if they all applied next year that's the
figure lba is estimating
todd and this is new spending this isn't
much money we're spending on education
now
talk about a thousand cuts
that's a hemorrhage
we have tried to fix it
you heard us try to fix it
the only option available now is to
repeal it
please let common sense and your sense
of frugality prevail
and vote no on this itl motion
representative luno has requested a roll
call we're coming down to the final
speaker is that sufficiently second it
is sufficiently seconded this is going
to be a roll call vote
we're down to the final speaker so
members take their seats
thank you mr speaker
the voucher plan is nothing less than an
attempt to dismantle our public schools
and replace them with private schools
we've heard that argument about the new
education freedom account program
but we first heard it back in 2011
with the debate about the tax credit
scholarship program
the same old proven false argument
and
since we're on the topic of education
we don't have a voucher plan the state's
are all have voucher plans
opponents can't get that right maybe we
need a lunch and learn program about uh
education freedom
and why are why are opponents so scared
of the education freedom programs
i remind am reminded of a quote
competition is always a good thing
it forces us to do our best
a monopoly renders people complacent and
satisfied with mediocrity
in a 2019 analysis of studies of the
impact on academics of choice programs
on public schools
24 studies
showed a positive effect of school
choice on the public schools
one neutral and one negative
so why are people scared
over eighteen hundred students are
enrolled in the program and remember
these are low-income students due to a
family income cap of 300 percent of
federal poverty
but hb 1683
would repeal and throw those kids out of
the program
what about them
are they just collateral damage yet
when we're talking about funding
and point out this is the only
program of its kind that has a phase out
of funding for students leaving a public
school
the first year after they leave
the school gets a hundred percent of
state funding plus all local funding
the second year
they get 50 percent
of state funding and all local funding
and the third year they get 25 percent
of state funding and local funding
the year after that they get all local
the minority report says that it is the
responsible thing to do
to repeal this program responsible
ask parents how responsible it is
yes again
opponents are scared scared because this
program is successful
yes more students selected efas than
originally
estimated and why is that
why is it above enrollment estimates
well the pandemic opened a window into
education and the parents have taken
notice a parents are standing up against
those who say they should not have a
role in their children's education
parents are standing up for education
options
parents are standing up and so should we
and we will
we will stand up for families and
children we will stand up for education
opportunities for new hampshire children
we will stand against this repeal
we will out itl this outrageous attempt
to destroy this program if children are
our future we must must provide them
with educational opportunities to be
successful
we will not fail these students and we
this
the motion before us is a majority
report of inexpedia to legislate on
house bill 1683 this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative luno for
thank you very much mr speaker
if i know new hampshire's 160 000 public
school kids perform among the best in
the country and that's what parents want
and if i know the state's voucher
program
is the most expansive
voucher program in the country and is
riddled with flaws
and if i know
that the voucher program
is clearly not as successful as some
proponents may suggest
given that the vast majority of the
voucher students
maybe around 200 um i'm sorry vast
majority of students maybe maybe around
1600 were already
attending private schools
and homeschooling situations
and if i know that this bill is the only
option left
since every other bill to improve the
financial responsibility
accountability and to prevent fraud has
been defeated
and if i know this bill will repeal a
program that steals from taxpayers and
is ripe for fraud and misuse
then would i press the red button to
overturn the itil motion so another
i recognize representative osborne for
thank you mr speaker
so if i believe that
every child is entitled to an adequate
education
but i know that a one-size-fits-all
program system cannot possibly provide
it to every child
and i know that this legislation before
us
would tear almost 2 000 children away
from their chosen environment and return
them to the inadequate educational
environment from once they came
would i now press the green button
the motion before us is the majority
report of in expediting to legislate on
house bill 1683 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're a publisher press
the red button voting stations are open
all
right all members president had an
opportunity to vote
109 189 voting yay 166 voting a
committee report is adopted
for what reason is a member rise
mr speaker can i move that the remarks
from the previous debate be
placed in the permanent journal
the motion before us is to print the
remarks
of the previous debate in the permanent
journal without objection
representative seaworth declared a
conflict of interest and did not
what reason did member rise mr speaker
i asked that house bill 1072 be removed
from the table and i asked my colleagues
sure
yes
so
theresa what was the amendment number do
mr speaker
don't worry about everything else just
yet i'll get the rest for you in a
so
okay the motion before us is to take
house bill 1072 off the table
i'm going to read it again
majority of the committee on criminal
justice and public safety to which was
referred house bill 1072
an act establishing a criminal penalty
for denying an elected school district
official access to any school district
facilities documents or events
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment a recommendation
the bill ought to pass with amendment
instead of terry roy for the majority of
the
committee the minority of the committee
on criminal justice and public safety to
which was referred house bill 1072 an
act establishing commental penalty
having considered the same report the
same being under the degree of majority
report with the following resolution
that is in expedient to legislate
representative ray newman from the
minority of the committee
seeing that we didn't adopt the
amendment before
the amendment is 0 8 9 3 h printed in
house record 10a pages
10.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment
the motion before us is to remove it
from the table
on house bill 1072 this is a division
vote
i understand that if you want to do one
we'll do one
i didn't say we can't do it i said we
don't have one
the chair recognizes representative
stephen pearson for a parliamentary
inquiry
if i know that having the amendment put
on this bill
gets rid of a lot of the problems and we
weren't able to do that
and if i know the debate discussion on
the situations that led up to this
are important to hear would i then press
the green button to remove this from the
table thank you sir
chair recognizer representative connolly
thank you mr speaker
if i know this bill makes
all student records including special
education plans
and private personnel records available
to budget committee members and school
board members
and if i know it would give these same
elected officials access to
entire school buildings including locker
rooms whenever they wish
and if i know this bill
threatens arrest to any school official
who
violates the law would i press the red
button to keep this bill on the table
motion before us is to take house bill
1072 off the table this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your post will press the
red button voting stations are open for
if all members president had an
house will attend to the state of the
vote
177 voting yeah 180 vote in a
i will let the body know that we are
majority of the committee on election
law to which was referred cacr15
an act relating to elections providing
the age
to vote in the primary election be
reduced to 17 for those who will be 18
by the general election having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment president wayne
mcdonald for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same been unable to agree
with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator connie
the amendment is 0735-hp
in house record 10a pages 1
and 2.
the chair recognizes representative
lebranch to speak against the committee
amendment
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
honorable colleagues
i rise today to oppose the committee
amendment on cacr15
the underlying cacr as titled as the
title would suggest would allow for 17
year olds to vote in the primary
elections if they are 18 by the general
election
i oppose this amendment for multiple
reasons
first it completely guts and replaces
the bill
secondly i believe that the underlying
bill would actually pass with by with a
bipartisan majority as the underlying
bill was actually sponsored
by the majority whip and the member from
londonderry who currently serves as the
chair of state and federal relations and
veterans affairs back in 2015.
it was also sponsored by the members
by other members back in 2019 most
notably the member from goffstown who
currently serves as the chair of the new
hampshire young republicans
the underlying cacr is also supported by
the new hampshire legislative youth
advisory council while the amendment is
opposed by the council
that is why i ask all of you to vote
down this amendment so that we can
debate the substance of the underlying
constitutional amendment and pass it
geo recognizer representative barbara
griffin
and thank you to the representative for
bringing the issue before the body
because it is always
great to learn something new about
processes in the house
because once a bill goes to a committee
it is the committees
and we know that in all of our
committees that we
as committee members then control
what goes forward in a bill
whether it is related to the original
subject
or not
after a hearing on what amendments might
be non-germane
and that is indeed as you just heard
what happened in this amendment
this representative from goffstown
didn't think that the underlying bill
had much chance of success before the
house
and this representative from goffstown
often disagrees with other
representatives from goffstown and that
is the point of this debate
of this hall
so the amendment that's brought before
you
is to raise an issue for your
consideration indeed about elections
about voting
and who should be voting in them
i actually disagreed that it was
non-germane
but we followed the process and that is
the bill that is before you today
and i ask that you support the amendment
so that we can have a debate on the
underlying issue that is before you now
by the majority vote of the committee
the motion before us
is the committee amendment
zero seven three five h
are you ready for the question
although
a division has been requested
who's requesting a roll call
senator barry requests the roll calls
officially it is sufficiently seconded
we're
the motion before us is the
vote on the amendment to
cacr15
this is the vote on the amendment
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you post you'll press the red button
mr speaker
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
192 voting a 163 voting a committee
the motion before us now was ought to
pass as amended chair recognizes
thank you mr speaker
the majority stated purpose in the
committee of this see this amendment
as amended the cacr
is to place the current statutory
definitions of resident
residency and domicile into the
constitution so that it will be harder
to change them in the future the
minority feels that the cacr is
unnecessarily
precisely because these definitions are
already in the statutes
but more importantly if we are going to
amend and put these
definitions into the constitution then
let's do it right
the language should be drafted
thoughtfully and carefully
so it's not to create more confusion
about an issue that this body has argued
about for years
and in court
if passed there will be five
qualifications
to vote in new hampshire
you must be a citizen of the united
states
you must be a citizen of new hampshire
you must be domiciled in new hampshire
new hampshire must be your primary
residency
and you can only vote where you are
domiciled
so let's look at the second and the
fourth requirements
both of which introduce undefined terms
into the qualifications to vote in new
hampshire
nowhere are the terms primary residency
or citizen of new hampshire defined not
in the cacr
and not in the statutes
the term primary residency implies that
there might be a secondary residency or
other types of residency
and what does it mean to be a citizen of
new hampshire
how is it different from being a citizen
of the united states
must you be a citizen of the united
states to be a citizen of new hampshire
is new hampshire going to start issuing
passports as one who testified on the
c-a-c-r inquired
this cacr creates creates unnecessary
confusion and will actually prolong the
debate over the definitions of domicile
and residency
and if passed in its current form
no not only will be it more difficult to
amend the bill
but it will insert even more uncertainty
into the already protracted debate
regarding what domicile means vis-a-vis
resident
representative barbara griffin has
requested a roll call we're down to our
final speaker
is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this is
going to be a roll call vote
we are down to our final speaker members
take your seats
chair recognizes representative berry
thank you mr speaker i'll keep my
remarks brief the cacr so it requires
two-thirds
mr speaker
the election law committee is attempting
to put to bed the endless debate in new
hampshire over who should vote in a new
hampshire election
the old domicile residency state of mind
we're trying to put that to bed
mr speaker we are saying that if new
hampshire is your primary residency
you get to vote here
we asked
people testifying about this bill how
many people do you think this will stop
from voting in new hampshire election
they said well realistically none
why because you should already be a
resident if you are voting here voting
is an act of residency
so mr speaker
this is a common sense reform
and the question before us is who should
vote in a new hampshire election
residents of new hampshire
or residents
and non-residents of new hampshire so mr
speaker if you believe
that non-residents should be voting in
new hampshire elections
oppose this
mr speaker if you believe that only
residents of new hampshire should be
voting in new hampshire
the motion before us is the ought the
majority ought to pass as amended on
cacr15
this is a roll call vote
members be in your seats
the chair recognizes representative
thank you mr speaker
if i knew
that cacr 15
would not resolve
ambiguities
could the representative just suspend
good to go
thank you mr speaker if i knew that cacr
15 would not resolve ambiguities but
would actually
introduce new ambiguities
into the venerable new hampshire
constitution of 1783
and if i believed that cacr 15
might impede ballot access
for voters who move frequently
because their housing is insecure would
i press the red button so a new motion
geo recognizes representative barbara
griffin for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this legislative body in
multiple prior sessions has considered
bills for statutes which can be changed
by this body addressing the
qualification of voters and if i know
that the new hampshire constitution
provides for a domicile qualification
while in statute at this time domicile
and residency have been defined and made
equivalent and mr speaker if i agree
that having these terms in our
constitution is important today and in
the future to make sure that only
legally qualified persons of new
hampshire are voting in new hampshire
would i now press the green button
thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is the majority
report about to pass as amended on cacr
15. this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
all members president an opportunity to
vote
we had 190 days 165 days
it did not meet the three fish
requirement of 235 so the motion to pass
fails
we're voting on whether or not to adopt
we already voted we voted on the
amendment and this was on the op ought
to pass as amended i apologize for my
confusion i asked in remarks on this
debate be printed in the permanent
journal
we would need a separate motion
for printing their remarks
and i have a feeling that's coming
uh mr speaker
am i allowed to speak stage emotion i'm
motioned to print the remarks in the
journal
the motion before us is to print the
remarks in the journal without objection
all right if everybody will stay in your
seat the next bill
is a division with parliamentary
majority of the committee on election
law to which was referred cacr19
an act relating to paper ballots
providing that all elections should be
conducted through paper ballots having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass present of catherine prudent
o'brien from the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
russell morehead for the minority of the
committee
representative mcguire requests the roll
call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
oh
the motion before us is the majority
report about to pass
on
cacr19 this is a roll call vote the
chair recognizes house will be in order
chair recognizes representative
if i knew
that current law
already does what this cacr
proposes to do
which is to require that new hampshire
elections
be conducted using paper ballots
and if i knew that in public hearings
before the election law committee
the committee learned of no one who's
suggesting that current law
in this respect be changed in any way
and if i believed that this cacr
in practice would function
to validate
unfounded fears
that new hampshire elections lack
integrity
rather than
functioning to solve real problems
would i press the red button
so a new motion could be made thank you
geo recognizes representative erosion
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that paper ballots
are vital in any election
if i further know that a paper trail
left behind from a paper ballot can
survive long after a memory card
has been wiped clean
would i then mr speaker
codifying new hampshire constitution
part first article 11 the following
requirement
article 11a paper ballots required for
purposes of facilitating
the examination and recounting of votes
cast
all elections shall be conducted using
paper ballots
and finally if i know
voter integrity is important to the
citizens of this great state
but i now press the green button to vote
yes and support the committee
recommendation of auto pass
motion before us
is the majority committee report who
ought to pass on cacr19 it's a roll call
vote you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
mr speaker
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
under a 95 voting a 160 voting a
for
state your point of order
mr speaker on the last cacr
it was not a two-thirds majority and you
no i said
majority of the committee on election
law to which was referred house bill
an act requiring the date a person
registered to vote to be included with
other voter information and considered
the same report the same with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass in of joe sweeney for the majority
of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution result that is
inexpedient to legislate senator paul
bergeron from the minority of the
committee
chair recognizes representative bergeron
thank you mr speaker
house bill
1009 would require that the data person
registers to vote be included with other
voter information in election net
that's being done now and it's been done
since 2006
when the state launched the statewide
voter registration database which was
required under the federal help america
vote act
there's a field titled date of voter
information which is the date of voter
registration
right now the date of registration is
confidential
if the bill passes the date of
registration will still be confidential
the data fields that are printed on a
checklist under state law now name
domicile mailing address
if different from domicile and party
affiliation
the bill does not require that the date
of registration be printed on the
checklist
so what will this bill do
and here's the problem prior to the
launch of election net
towns and cities maintain their own
voter registration databases
whose primary purpose was to generate
the checklist that would be used at the
polls
since the date voters registered to vote
wasn't needed to print a checklist that
information wasn't contained in the
database
so the bill creates an unfunded mandate
there's no grandfather clause here
in 2006 our towns and cities migrated
approximately eight hundred and twenty
five thousand voter records into
election net
most did not include the voters
registration date
since there's no grandfather clause
the bill require that communities scour
their databases identify the pre-2006
voter records in an election that do not
have a date of voter registration pull
the paper record and then key in the
updated voter registration information
article 28a of the constitution
prohibits the state from mandating any
new expanded or modified programs or
responsibilities to any political
subdivision in such a way as to
necessitate additional local
expenditures
house bill 1009 would require that
election officials bear the cost of
keying and data for the pre-2006 records
without providing a means to reimburse
the communities for their costs in doing
so
please press the no red button
to overturn the committee recommendation
so that another motion can be made and
chair recognizes representative sweeney
speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker mr speaker house
bill 1009 is a simple bill that adds to
the checklist available to the public
the date a voter registers to vote
knowing when people register to vote and
having that as public information can
empower granite staters to have a clear
view when considering policy the
secretary of state's office largely has
this data for most voters
i don't disagree about the pre-2006
voters
but there and we will continue as a
state to collect this information as we
go forward as new people are added to
the voter registration rules
there's nothing nefarious or untoward
about this legislation as proposed
there's nothing wrong with putting this
information on the checklist as we've
described it is simply another data
point added to a sea of data points that
will enable the political parties
candidates and the public at large to
have a greater view of the voter
registration process and who and when
people are registering to vote
i urge you all to vote in favor of our
majority ought to pass recommendation on
representative christian chris a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote members take your seats
so
[Music]
the motion before us is the majority
report about to pass on house bill
senator read then one zero zero nine
this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that the date of voter
registration is confidential and exempt
from the right to know law
and if i know that this legislation is
not needed for candidates in political
organizations to effectively get out the
vote
would i then press the red button to
defeat this motion so another motion
i recognize representative alexander for
thank you mr speaker if i know hp 1009
helps to shine a light on elections by
making the date of vote voter registers
public and if i know the secretary of
state's office largely has this data for
most voters and will continue to collect
information and record it on voters
going forward
would i now press the green button to
support making public information
the motion before us is the ought to
pass majority report of auto pass on
house bill 1009
it's a roll call vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed to press the
red button voting stations are open for
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
185 voting a 167 voting nay committee
we're going to take up one more bill
jury the committee on election law to
which was referred house bill 1082 an
act prohibiting certain state officers
from forming political action committees
having considered the same report the
same of the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass senate catherine prudhomme
o'brien for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same they will agree with
the majority report with the following
resolution resolve that is inexpedient
to legislate senator paul bergeron from
the minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative bergeron
thank you mr speaker
this bill would prevent candidates who
seek to run for secretary of state or
state treasurer from forming political
action committees in their name
not somebody else's name but in their
name since the 1976 supreme court ruling
the right to participate in democracy
through political contributions has been
protected by the first amendment
in its ruling the court said that quote
virtually every means of communicating
ideas in today's mass society
requires the expenditure of money
the distribution of handbills or
leaflets entails printing paper and
circulation costs
it costs money
the electorate's dependence on these
communications for information has made
these modes of contact indispensable
instruments of effective political
speech
end quote
i received one of these flyers that cost
money
on the way in to the chambers yesterday
and it actually summarizes quite well
the point that i'm trying to make
standing here at the podium today
it refers to house bill 1082 and it says
this bill limits political speech by
prohibiting candidates for secretary of
state and state treasurer or current
office holders of these positions from
forming a political committee or
political advocacy organization or
soliciting contributions for such
organizations
it continues part one article 22 of the
new hampshire constitution states
free speech and liberty the press are
essential to the security of freedom in
the state
they ought therefore to be inviolably
preserved and quote
and it finals it ends with its position
limits on all speech and particularly
political speech may be a tempting
solution to a perceived problem but it
is not a proper solution
during the public hearing on this bill
in in the majority report
the sponsor cited the quote nonpartisan
nature of these two offices as just as
justification
for these fundraising restrictions
i don't think i need to remind you that
all our town and city elections are
non-partisan in nature too
i hate to open the door to think that we
wouldn't be able to have pacs in our
names if we were running for election or
re-election
finally this bill would have a severe
impact on the ability of candidates for
secretary of state and state treasurer
to gather the financial resources needed
to effectively communicate with those
who will cast votes in those elections
and would pose in restrictions
restrictions that our state and our
federal constitutions cannot tolerate
please press the red no button to
overturn the committee recommendation so
that another motion may be made and mr
speaker i request a division vote
is the member yielded questions uh he
uh thank you um
you know it it may surprise people to
hear this i'm i'm still actually
undecided on this bill and i have a
technical question that i'm i'm hoping
you can
sort of enlighten me on
as most of us are probably all aware in
new hampshire we we define
pac and candidate committee separately
and um i can't find an answer if this
bill
includes candidate committees in
addition to a regular pac or if it's
thank you for the question
based on my limited knowledge of
campaign finance laws i consider a pac
and a candidate committee the same thing
in terms of filing reports with the
secretary of state's office
does remember yield a further question
no further questions
member does not yield
chair recognizes representative rayne
thank you mr speaker
this legislature and its wisdom
made the office of secretary of state
and state treasurer nonpartisan in 1997
when it amended rsa14 colon 2-b
while i didn't have the honor of being a
member of this body back then
i said i understand that at least part
of the reason for having done so
was because these offices are not
partisan in nature and really should not
be political in nature
the political aspect of new hampshire
elections is handled by our two great
political parties and should not in any
way be found in the department of state
along that same line the administration
of state finances should not be a
political matter but a sensible
professional and straightforward one
i understand the contention that
municipal candidates all over the state
are also nonpartisan
and can and would still be able to farm
packs even if this bill were passed
however
they are seeking the votes of thousands
of people in a popularly elected
while we may call our decisions on
secretary of state and state treasurer
and election
what they really amount to are
appointments by a government body
candidates for these constitutional
offices are seeking the support of only
a few hundred
new hampshire is one of three states in
which these officials are elected by the
state legislature and not by the general
electorate
in maine one of the other two states
forming pacs is prohibited by those who
would seek and serve in these offices
in tennessee the third state the concept
is viewed as so inappropriate that no
one does it
on an occasion in recent years when such
a pac was formed in new hampshire
it was similarly received with
disapproval
the best example of the need to maintain
the integrity and non-political
nonpartisan nature of the secretary of
state's office in particular
is the legacy of former secretary
william gardner
secretary gardner a lifelong democrat
served this state well for four and a
half decades
and was elected repeatedly by both
republican and democrat majorities in
this legislature
he was so elected and re-elected because
of his effective
fair even-handed management of new
hampshire's elections
allowing candidates for secretary of
state and state treasurer
to form political action committees
would dangerously and unnecessarily
inject politics and possible conflicts
of interest into these important offices
and do so to the disservice of new
hampshire's citizens
i urge you to support the majority
octopass recommendation of the election
law committee thank you mr speaker does
the member yield to questions i do not
this is a division vote members will
uh
so
the motion before us is the majority
report about to pass as amended ought to
pass
on house bill 108-2
this is a division vote the chair
recognizes representative muirhead for
if i knew that this bill would make it
impossible for persons who were
interested in serving
as the secretary of state
or the state treasurer to make their
names known
to the citizens of the state and to make
their qualities known to the citizens of
the state and if i knew
that public ignorance
of those persons who are interested in
serving as secretary of state and
treasurer
would undermine or diminish democratic
accountability and
and might empower
insiders
then would i press the red button so a
made the chair recognizes representative
pewter
through home o'brien for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker
if i know
that in maine
a nearly identical bill to this was
passed after that state suffered from
corruption
of their treasurer
in the mid-1990s
that there's a full month between when
we are elected and then organization day
a full month that candidates for
treasurer or secretary of state
can call us or email us contact us come
to our house
they don't need a political action
committee for that they just need a
telephone or an email address
or a or an automobile would i now press
green to support the committee
the motion before us is a majority
report of autopass on house bill 1082
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed or press the red button
[Music]
okay
house will be in order
177 voting yeah 176 voting nay the
speaker did vote to break a tie
representative
dotsy
okay there
uh
first of all i would like to apologize
for
oh my mask
my mask
first of all i would like to apologize
for my faux pas yesterday
uh when i inadvertently walked uh in
front of the diaz um
that was a mistake it was a senior
moment
and since i'm only 39
that's surprising but it happened so
the other announcement i would like to
make is that the secular values
legislative caucus is meeting today
in the
conference room in the clerk's office
and this is for all people in the
chamber religious or non-religious and
it's basically
about
discussing our if you're committed to
secular values then we would like to see
you with the caucus and have a nice
chair recognizes representative lang for
one two three four there we go thank you
mr speaker first off representative bean
please call your wife she texted me your
phone's off number two um remember we're
doing our food drive for through april
10th
every pound of food we collect we have
some sponsors who are going to be giving
us money for our two charities which
will go to support domestic violence
prevention program and veterans homeless
veterans relief programs so if you're
coming in tomorrow remember there's
boxes in the back there's boxes here
there's boxes over the lob please bring
in some food drop it in there so we can
get some pounds and get some money for
our charities thank you
the clerk
clerk has an announcement thank you mr
speaker i was asked by our custodial
staff
last night after session
many members
left
dirty tissues
filled water bottles and other various
sorts of trash on the floor in the
chamber
please if you hike it in hike it out
secondly just a a very firm reminder
again
if you do not vote in the 30 seconds
your machine is shut off do not attempt
to push it or beat it up after the 30
seconds have ended i will call your name
and you need to give me a thumbs up or
majority of the committee on election
law to which was referred house bill
and act relative to absentee ballot
requests having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that bill otter passed it's an appealing
corrosion for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senate paul
bergeron for the minority of the
committee
thank you mr speaker
this bill proposes to amend rsa 657
colon 12 relative to absentee voting
the statute currently states that quote
upon receipt of a properly executed
application for an absentee ballot a
town or clerk shall ascertain if the
applicant is on the checklist and if so
the clerk shall send the materials end
quote
this bill proposes adding the following
sentence to that statute quote under no
circumstances shall a town or city clerk
mail an absentee ballot
unless and until such person has
submitted a absentee ballot application
the town of clerk has approved the
application end quote
in short the bill says the same thing
that the statute already says
no substance is being added to the
statute that isn't already there
among the principles of good legal
writing unnecessary or extra words
should be removed redundancy should be
avoided and different words should not
be used to say the same thing
house bill 1153 is poorly crafted adds
nothing to existing law and is totally
unnecessary
please press the red no button to
overturn the committee recommendation so
that another emotion may be made and mr
a division vote has been requested we're
down to the last speaker members take
your seats
chair recognizes representative clearly
thank you mr speaker
this legislation proposes a change in
rsa 657 colon 12
to clarify and reinforce the requirement
that absentee ballots may be mailed to
absentee voters only after an absentee
ballot application has been received and
approved by the town or city clerk
the necessity for this clarification was
demonstrated by testimony before the
election law committee which revealed
that some clerks include the actual
absentee ballot when responding by mail
to request for voter registration forms
and absentee ballot applications
the result is that some unregistered
applicants
receive absentee ballots before becoming
a registered voter
and before their absentee ballot
applications have been properly
certified
members appreciate that as clarified by
this legislation
clerks will have to perform two mailings
one to send the application forms and
one to send the absentee ballot
however the majority of the election law
committee believes that the requirement
is worthwhile
to ensure that registrations are
processed before a registrant is
provided an absentee ballot
this will enhance election integrity
by preventing official absentee ballots
from going to unregistered voters
who that may not have the right to vote
in new hampshire
i therefore respectfully request
that you press the green button to vote
yes on the ought to pass motion as
recommended by the majority of election
law committee thank you
sir bel desaro has requested a roll call
as that's officially seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
motion before us is the majority report
about a pass on house bill 1153
this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
thank you mr speaker
if i know that nothing is being added to
the statute that isn't already there
and if i know that the absentee voter
registration and absentee balloting
process described by the previous
speaker appears in a different statute
if i know that house bill 1153 is poorly
crafted redundant and totally
unnecessary but i then press the red no
button so the subsequent motion may be
made thank you
chair recognizes representative berry
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that during testimony on this bill
a town clerk admitted to mailing ballots
actual ballots mr speaker to
unregistered voters people who were not
on the voter rolls actual ballots would
i now mr speaker press the green button
so such a practice can no longer take
place
the majority report
is ought to pass as
ought to pass
on house bill 1153 house will come to
order
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you press
the red button voting stations are open
so
awesome
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
185 voting a 158 voting aid the
the jury the committee on election law
to which was referred house bill 1203 fn
act relative to domicile residency voter
registration and investigation of voter
verification letters relative to the
terms resident inhabitant residency
and residency
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with amendment is in fentanyl
grown for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate senator paul
bergeron for the minority of the
committee
the amendment
is 0 9 6 2 h printed in house record 10
a
pages 19 through 26.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
the motion before us now is out to pass
says amendment to chair recognizing
representative bergeron to speak against
thank you mr speaker
this bill is amended revises statutes
that were amended by senate bill 3
during the 2017 session
those provisions were subsequently
struck down by the new hampshire supreme
court which found that they imposed
unreasonable burdens on the right to
vote the minority agrees that there's a
need to clean up the statutes affected
by senate bill 3 in light of that ruling
but this last minute amendment does not
accomplish that
the bill retains a two-tiered voter
registration system which the court
found was unnecessary
and it introduces new confusions that
will invite new litigation
for example
a person who registers to vote 30 days
or less before an election
and who doesn't have proof of residency
can sign an affidavit if he acknowledges
that his domicile may be verified
a person who registers more than 30 days
before an election does not have that
option they cannot sign that residency
affidavit instead they sign one in which
they're swearing that quote they will
not ever be able to possess any
qualifying documents of domicile
end quote
if i were homeless i sure wouldn't want
to swear under penalty of fines that i
would be forever homeless but here's
another example and this is a true story
and it's the kind of situation that
often occurs with new new residents to
our communities
just before i retired as city clerk in
nashua came a woman came into our office
she happened to
i happen to be the one assisting her at
the counter
she and
she had just gotten married a couple of
weeks prior
she and her husband had come in for the
marriage license about a month prior to
that previously she lived in tyngsboro
her husband lived in nashua he was
renting a condo in nashua
so after they were married she moved in
with them
the lease was in his name all the
utilities were in his name
and she wanted and needed to get a new
hampshire driver's license because she
needed to do that within two months of
moving to new hampshire
she brought her marriage certificate
along with the copy of her husband's
lease and her husband's utility bill
because nothing had been changed over
yet
both of which had her husband's name on
them and when she tried to get a
driver's license she was refused
the person at dmv actually told her that
the marriage certificate didn't prove
that she lived with her husband at that
address
so she wanted to register to vote to
have proof of where she lived
now i knew that they had come in they
had got the license i knew her where her
husband lived i had no problems
whatsoever of registering that person to
vote
of course i can't do it if this couldn't
have done it if this bill was in effect
because she had no physical evidence of
domicile and could not swear that she
would quote not ever be able to possess
any qualifying
documents at domicile she was not would
not be eligible to register to vote
under this law as it's written
another litigation concern
the voter registration form for citizens
registering to vote 30 days prior to an
election
states that the applicant has to swear
that to make that he has to make the
address i have entered above my domicile
for voting i must have an intent to make
this the one place from which i
participate in democratic
self-government and must have acted to
carry out that intent
i have no idea what must have acted to
carry out that intent means the
expression is undefined unexplained
the minority is concerned that the bill
will make ballot access more confusing
and difficult for some citizens to
register to vote and the courts will end
up having to weigh in again because we
rush through this amended bill it needs
more work
please press the red no button to
overturn the committee recommendation so
that another motion may be made and mr
eric and as representative groan speak
thank you mr speaker
hb 1203 was introduced to remove
language from the rsa that is no longer
used because of a supreme court decision
and to restore
some necessary language that existed in
the rsa prior to that decision however
hb 1203 as introduced as introduced
would have weakened the domicile
residency requirements for voting in new
hampshire for example 654 colon one
the section that deals with the person's
claim of domicile was amended to add a
person's claim of domicile for voting
purposes shall not be conclusive of the
person's residence for any other purpose
amendment
962-h amends hb 1203 to replace all
after the enacting clause
as amended hb 1203 removes the language
regarding voter
registration forms and voter affidavits
that is no longer used because of the
court decision
and it restores some language as i
mentioned that existed in the rsa prior
to the court decision
this
language
is supported by the secretary of state's
office i also added it this bill also
adds language to strengthen and clarify
the forms and processes used for
registration prior to 30 days before an
election and the forms and processes
used for voting within or registering
within 30 days
of election or on election day
the intent of this language is to ensure
that every qualified new hampshire voter
has a right to register and vote
it is also to assure to the best we can
that persons who are not qualified to
vote in new hampshire should not be
allowed to vote in new hampshire and
thereby dilute the vote of those who are
qualified to vote in new hampshire i
urge you to support the election law
committee's recommendation of ought to
a division has been requested this will
be a division vote members take your
seats
so
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of what a passes
amended on house bill 1203
chair recognizes representative horrigan
thank you very much mr speaker um before
i start the p.i i have a very quick
question was
i was under the impression we were going
to have a floor fight over the amendment
which
you're recognized for parliamentary
inquiry okay so
the real parliamentary in korea is
trying to make us out of order that's
fine
thank you and thank you mr speaker
if i know that the hp 1203 as amended is
so poorly drafted it's hard to tell
exactly what it does even after i reread
it several times
but if i was able to discern that this
amendment does not protect the right to
vote and does not simplify the voter
registration process and the general
does pretty much the exact opposite of
what
myself the prime sponsor of this bill
and the co-sponsors intended
and um
so find out so
representative you're recognized for
parliamentary inquiry yes i
i thought i was thought i was giving one
so if i know
that this amendment um does not do what
the sponsor is intended
when i then press the red button
so that an alternative motion can be
can be considered thank you mr speaker
geo recognizer of senator barbara
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this bill has amended
makes changes to our election laws that
will make them consistent with what the
practice is
making them easier for persons to
understand
and if i know that this amendment
continues to allow for affidavits of
proof of eligibility to include domicile
for persons registering on election day
and for certain qualifications 30 days
before
and finally if i know that this
legislation does not create any
unreasonable burdens on the right to
vote would i now press the green button
thank you mr speaker
motion before us the majority committee
reported what a passage is amended on
house bill 1203 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
mr speaker you got to read the thing
it was
it was close it was closed out before
okay if everybody will stay in their
seats we have a division with just
parliamentary inquiries majority of the
majority committee on election law to
which was referred house bill 1247
an act relative to folded ballots having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate senator paul
bergeron for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same would be an noble
degree with a majority
report with a recommendation that the
bill ought to pass representation for
the minority of the committee
a roll call has been requested by
representative blazik is that
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is the majority
report of inexpedient to legislate on
house bill one two four seven
the chair recognizes representative
peter teroshan for a
prob
mr speaker if i know
house bill 1247 would require that in
any political subdivision that uses
any ballot that has been folded by
any ballot that has unfolded uh be held
for counting after the polls close
and if i know the wyndham audit
found that some folded ballots were not
read properly
by ballot counting machines due to a
shadow
created by the fold running the scanner
unable to accurately score the results
mr speaker i further know
that we would never have
known the real intent of those voters
if an audit had not been performed
if i believe there's reason to think
this can happen under other
circumstances
and if i know towns already hand count
ballots when there's a write-in
candidate on the ballot and that works
just fine
and finally if i know that this
legislation
would add an additional measure of
security by requiring all folder ballots
to be hand counted
but i now press the red button
to overturn the ital motion to ensure
that every vote counts in return
confidence to voters that the new
hampshire legislature
takes seriously the responsibility to
safeguard the election process red
button please thank you mr speaker
i recognize the representative hammer
thank you mr speaker
if i know that hand counting ballots
after the polls close we'll add another
four to five hours to the 14-hour day
already put in
by our overworked election workers
and if i know that one-third of the
ballots cast in the 2020 general
election were folded ballots
and if i know that the committee's
bipartisan majority
knows that the local moderators already
have the authority to direct that
absentee ballot
be tallied by hand and the decision
be should be left up to the discretion
of the local election officials
would i now vote yes and push the green
button to keep the bill as itl thank you
the motion before us the majority report
of index being to legislate on house
bill 1247
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
no
representative hambly
representative
well members president had an
opportunity to vote
i guess i don't need to say house will
attend to the state of the road
203 voting 145 voting a
conversions
there's
is
so
12-16
chair recognizes representative weber
for a motion
thank you mr speaker representatives
weber and griffin root move that in
light of the changing season and
increasing warmth in the chamber the
gentleman be able to remove their
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
committee on election
committee on election law which to which
was referred house bill
1264 establishing rank just voting for
the state party primary elections and
representative reed
0909 h on page 3637
and the chair recognizes representative
you're recognized to speak
j recognizes what the reason is a member
rise
mr speaker promotion state your motion
i'd like to make a motion we table this
bill
house bill 1264 be laid on the table
a division has been requested
okay
so
the motion before us is to lay house
bill 1264 on the table
this is a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
barbara griffin for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that the subject of this bill
comes without recommendation from the
committee
ensuring long debates on the issues
presented by this bill
and if i know
that even if passed this bill would have
no impact on upcoming elections in 2022
and none on local elections in 2023
because of the process that needs to be
followed for a community to opt in
and if i know
that this purports to be enabling
legislation but none of the entities it
purports to be enabling asked for it
would i now press the green button to
table this bill
chair recognizes representative craig
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that no party political party or
municipality would be required to opt
into this optional system of ranked
choice voting
and if i know
that the organizations which have opted
in and successfully used rank choice
voting include the republican parties of
utah illinois and virginia
and if i know that supporters political
philosophies range from progressive to
libertarian to
very conservative but i now press the
red button
so the debate on this bill may continue
the motion before us is a tabling motion
on house bill one two six four
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
so
mr speaker
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
206 voting yay 142 voting a hb 12 64 is
majority of the committee on election
law to which was referred house bill
act relative to permissible campaign
contributions by business organizations
and labor unions having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate
joe alexander from the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
senator connie lane from the minority of
the committee
chair recognizes representative lane
thank you mr speaker
this bill creates a level playing field
between
unions
and corporations with respect to
political contributions
currently business organizations can
donate to political campaigns regardless
of how that money is generated within
the company either in its general
treasury or for funds specifically
raised for political donations
but
labor unions are only limited can only
use funds that are raised specifically
for political donations
this bill applies the same rules for
both types of organizations allowing
contributions only from funds
specifically earmarked for political
contributions
this bill is the solution that was
proposed by judge mcauliffe in his 1999
opinion when he declared the broadband
on all corporate
contributions unconstitutional
he recommended that business
organizations be limited to usually
using only specifically segregated funds
rather than those from the company's
general treasurer
instead this body changed the law so
that corporations have no restrictions
on where their campaign contributions
come come from creating an unfair
advantage for corporations over labor
unions
it does not adversely affect the first
amendment of business organizations just
as it does not adversely affect those of
labor unions all the bill does is apply
consistent rules for both types of
organizations please vote against the
committee's report
of ito
and i
respectfully ask for a division vote mr
speaker
a division vote has been requested we
are down to our last speaker members
take their seats
chair recognizes representative sweeney
to speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker mr speaker house
bill 1326
upends the process for employers and
granite state businesses to engage in
the political process
this body spearheaded and the governor
signed comprehensive campaign finance
reform just last year the united states
supreme court has ruled time and time
again
that political contributions to
campaigns or organizations are a form of
free speech protected by the first
amendment
regulating them in the manner that is
proposed in house bill 1326 would be a
stringent and burdensome over regulation
of our first amendment rights
and i urge you all to vote in favor of
our majority in expedient to legislate
motion before us is the majority report
i've been experiencing to legislate on
house bill 1326
this is a division vote
members
[Music]
we're already in the voting mode for a
division
the motion before us is any speeding to
legislate on house bill 1326 this is a
division vote
this
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button
if you're opposed your
[Music]
chair recognizes representative
if i know that
hb
puts
unions
on a fair and equal footing
with corporations with respect to
political engagement
well i press the red button so a new
i recognize representative sweeney for
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker mr speaker if i know that house
bill 1326 infringes on the first
amendment rights of our constituents and
further mr speaker if i know that this
body already passed comprehensive
campaign finance reform just last year
would i now support the majority report
of index feeding to legislate by
pressing the green button thank you
the worst before us is the majority
committee reported been expedient to the
legislator and house bill 1326 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're
approached or press the red button
[Music]
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
state of the vote
under an 85 voting a 161 voting a
majority of the committee on election
law to which was referred house bill
1394 and act relative to the reporting
of certain campaign contributions
relative to political contributions made
by limited liability companies consider
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpensive to legislate
president joe sweeney the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass senator connie lane for the
minority of the committee chair
recognizes representative lane to speak
thank you mr speaker
this bill clarifies that individual
members of a limited liability company
are subject to the same political
campaign contribution limits
as our individuals such as us and
corporations
presently each llc is treated separately
for the purpose of direct campaign
contributions regardless of who controls
it or who belongs to it
candidates can receive multiple
contributions from separate llcs
which are often created at the same
address and controlled by the same
person corporation or group of people
these members of the members of the llcs
whether individuals or corporations are
allowed to spend over the statutory
campaign limits set for them by using
this loophole which has become known as
the llc lupo
this bill would close that
making the existing contribution limits
meaning meaningful
because without them they're meaningless
without it individuals and corporations
can form numerous llc's to get around
the caps
this bill is not in violation of
anyone's first amendment rights as some
have claimed
just as campaign limits for individuals
and corporations are not violations of
their first amendment rights all this
does is close the loophole available now
only to llcs
this bill is a campaign financing bill
that increases transparency and
accountability
and the fact that we did campaign
financing last year doesn't mean we can
continue to clean up campaign financing
this year
thank you mr speaker and i would ask for
representative berry has asked for a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
we are down to the last speaker it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote members take your seats
chair recognizes representative sweeney
to speak for the committee report thank
you mr speaker mr speaker house bill
is a bill that simply cannot and should
not work for new hampshire this proposed
legislation will require political
contributions made by an llc to be
attributed to the member of the llc and
counted against their contribution limit
however
we don't track memberships of llcs in
the state of new hampshire you could
have a one-member llc or a 50-member llc
and no existing state statute or
proposed state statute by this
legislation would report to the public
or to any state agency the membership of
that llc a contribution from an llc is
viewed the same as a contribution from
an individual in state law and in court
findings and we should not upend that
process
this body considered nearly identical
legislation last year and we found it
inexpedient to legislate then and we
should find it inexpedient to legislate
the motion before us is the majority
report of an expedient to legislate
on house bill 1394 this is a roll call
vote
the chair recognizes representative
thank you mr speaker
if i knew
that this bill shines a light
would i vote against the itl by pressing
the red button
so that a new motion could be made thank
you
chair recognizes representative barry
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know this bill
would have unintended consequences and
result in not only campaign finance
issues but also reporting issues with
the secretary of state via the quick
start system would i now press the green
button to oppo to support the itl motion
the motion before us is a majority
committee reporter been expedient to
legislator in house bill 1394. it's the
roll call vote if you're in favor you
press the green button if you post you
press the red button voting stations are
baltimore mr president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
under an 87 voting yay 163 vonnie nay
our next two bills are just
divisions and parliamentary inquiries so
don't go wandering off too far
majority of the committee on election
law to which was referred house bill
1442-fn
act relative to access to election and
voter information having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate senate of ross berry for
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and then will agree
with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study senator connie lane
for the minority of the committee
a division has been requested this will
be a division vote members take your
seats
the moisture before says the majority
report of index being to legislator in
house bill one four four two this is a
division vote chair recognize
representative of hamlet for a
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that the population of new
hampshire is becoming more diverse
and if i know that our voting
instructions and ballots may be above
the reading level that is required for
the citizenship test
and if i know that with more research
and revisions this bill could be
improved
would i then press the red button to
defeat this motion so another motion
could be made
thank you
i reckon as representative haywood for
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that hb 1442 fn
the federal standard from five percent
lowers the federal standard
from five percent to 3
without any rationale
or population data to support a stricter
new hampshire standard
which even at 3 percent does not apply
anywhere in the state
and mr speaker
if i know that this requirement
especially the third language
could be inordinately expensive and in
some cases
a legally defensible translation may not
be possible
and finally mr speaker if at some future
point the new hampshire population
demographics do change sufficiently
to warrant a multi-language ballot
we should start with a blank sheet of
paper
not hb 1442.
mr speaker
motion before us the majority report of
innings media legislator in house bill
this is a division vote if you're in
favor press the green button pose press
the red button
representative
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
under a 95 voting a 156 phoney nay
this again is a division vote with just
parliamentary inquiries so members will
stay in their seats
majority of the committee on election
law to which was referred house bill
1567 fn
act relative to the removal of election
officials from office have been
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment senator barbara
griffin for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate
president paul bergeron for the minority
of the committee
the amendment
is one zero one four h printing and
house record 10 a pages 78-79
the question is on the amendment are you
ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it and the amendment is
adopted
the question before us is the majority
report of ought to pass as amended
this is a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this bill is amended
would fine municipalities whose election
officials
negligently failed to perform their
duties
and if i know that negligence is a
concept that is not defined in state law
and if i know that the bill lacks
clarity as to who can file a complaint
relative to negligence whom it should be
filed with and how that complaint is to
be investigated
would i then press the red no button so
i recognize the representation for a
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that local election
officials must perform their election
related duties properly
to ensure the integrity of our elections
and if i know there have been recent
well-documented new hampshire instances
of substantial negligence
by local election officials
and furthermore mr speaker if i know
that assessing significant fines against
municipalities who elections whose
election officials have been negligent
would help incentify incentivize those
municipalities to ensure their elections
are conducted in accordance with the law
and finally mr speaker if i know that
this legislation would also help
preserve public confidence in the
integrity of our elections
would i then vote yes to the ought to
pass motion for this bill by pressing
the green button
thank you
motion before us as the majority
committee report about to pass as
amended on house bill 1567
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you request
the red button voting stations are open
you have to give me a thumb up
representative
president had an opportunity to vote
under an 87 voting a 165 voting a
majority on committee on environment
agriculture to which was referred house
bill 1454 fn
an act relative to permits for the
sitting of new landfills
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment and
the recommendation bill ought to pass
with amendment representative megan
murray
majority the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate
presenter barbara contoir for the
minority of the committee
the amendment is 0894-h
printed in house record 10a page 61. are
you ready for the vote on the amendment
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
the question before us is ought to pass
on with amendment are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the guys have it and the committee
the house will be in order
the majority of the committee on
executive departments and administration
which was referred to house bill 1065 fn
an act relative to the regulation of art
therapists having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is an
expediential legislate representative
matthew santo nostalgia for the majority
of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment representative
william marsh for the minority of the
committee
what reason does a member ask
for a motion
state your motion
i'd like to put house bill 1065 on the
table
representative mcguire moves to lay
house bill 1065 on the table
division has been requested this will be
i also come to order the question is
whether to lay house bill 1065 on the
table
representative marsh is recognized for
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that new hampshire
currently has a desperate shortage of
mental health practitioners and patients
are suffering as a result
and if i know that in 14 states in the
district of columbia art therapists have
been allowed to have licenses to
practice in this capacity
and if i believe granting such licenses
now would reduce the current burden on
our
substantially overburdened mental health
care practitioners when i then press the
red button so that we can allow the
as a reminder we're in the voting mode
representative mcguire is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that art
therapists are regulated by the state
and
quite a few of them do in fact practice
in new hampshire
and if i know that they appear to be
very happy with this regulation because
none of them came and bothered the dna
committee
would i not press the green button to
table house bill 1065.
the question is whether lay house bill
1065 on the table this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll be
pressing the green button if you're
opposed press the red button voting
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
180 having voted in the affirmative 150
in the negative house bill 1065 is laid
the majority of the committee on
executive departments and administration
which was referred to house bill 1135 an
act requiring a performance audit of the
department of education education
freedom account program having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill octopass
with amendment representative tony
lakers for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
an expedient to legislate representative
sally fellows for the minority of the
committee
the committee amendment is zero eight
four seven h
the member from holderness
representative fellows is recognized to
i want to begin by saying that the
minority recommendation printed in the
calendar is incorrect it should be ought
to pass
the full committee supports an audit of
the education freedom accounts
not one person spoke against it we just
disagree on when the audit should take
place
the amendment delays it by one year
this program gives parents four thousand
to eight thousand dollars per child
which can be spent
or it can be kept on account to be used
in future years by the parents
the state will give an outside
contractor more than eight million
dollars this year and likely 16 million
dollars or more next year
it is our responsibility as state
representatives to ensure
that taxpayers money is being handled in
accordance with state laws and sound
financial management practices
this is not a financial audit
this is an audit of management
procedures
it will look at such things as how is
the income eligibility determined
this can be complicated
for married pare unmarried parents or
blended families
how is state
residency state residency verified
it can is it being done each year
do children and the parents actually
live in new hampshire
is their address a vacation home or the
home of a relative
does class wallet
a web application parents use to make
most of their purchases
favor
certain businesses or give them access
to protected personal data
the contractor is not pro non-profit and
class wallet is a subcontractor
which entity is holding the quarterly
payments from the state and where is
this money held in a bank account
in stocks in cryptocurrency
since the main focus of this audit is
accountability for state money and not
educational outcomes
next winter is not too soon for an audit
auditors will be able to review a year
and a half of financial data
and two years of eligibility
determinations
for more than three thousand students
as the director of the audit division
wrote in his letter to edna
early all audits quote
identify areas needing immediate
attention
and give an opportunity to fix those
issues immediately
please vote no on the amendment
so the audit can be published next year
and we can make any needed legislative
a division vote was requested on this
and we are at the final speaker the
member from hudson representative tony
lakers is recognized to speak in support
of the amendment
thank you mr speaker
i strongly support auditing the various
departments and programs in the
executive branch having those audits
done reviewing them and then following
up to make sure good recommendations for
change are implemented is an important
part of the job for this legislature
however
for an audit to provide useful
information a program has to have been
in place with stable rules for a minimum
of one year and preferably several years
that is the recommendation the committee
received from the director of the audit
division of the legislative budget
assistant
the problem is that the rules for the
education freedom account program were
just approved by the joint legislative
committee on administrative rules and
the final rules do differ significantly
from the interim rules that it started
with
also as we have seen
there are many bills before the house
that could affect this program and there
are more bills
before the other body if any of those
bills passed they would also affect the
operation of the program
if the state is to spend the resources
of the audit division to do the audit
and at the department of education to
provide information for that audit it
should be done in a time frame which
will provide useful information
if done too soon it won't be an audit of
the actual program as it operates and
would operate into the future that could
result in inconclusive and inaccurate
results from the audit the amendment to
this bill moves the effective date from
july of this year to july of 2023
doing so will ensure that there is at
least one full school year and fiscal
year of stable operations to the audit
please support this motion to adopt the
amendment to produce an effective audit
the question is whether to adopt
amendment zero eight four seven h this
is a division vote members please take
receipts
the question is on whether to adopt
amendment zero eight four seven h
representative fellows is recognized for
mr speaker if i believe we owe it to the
new hampshire taxpayers to verify that
state money is being handled
appropriately
that money is going only to qualified
students
and the contractors are following all
state laws
and if i believe we need to know as soon
as possible if there are any problems so
those problems can be corrected as soon
as possible will i now press the red
button
representative mcguire is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that a
performance audit is a major undertaking
on the part of the state
and if i know that the department of
education is currently undergoing a
performance audit on special education
programs and would find it difficult to
support a second one at the same time
and if i know
that the
audit division
strongly supports delaying this
performance audit would i not press the
green button to delay it by one year
the question is whether to adopt
amendment zero eight four seven h this
is a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
have all members president an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
187 having voted in the affirmative 148
and the negative the amendment's adopted
the question now is on the majority
committee report of ought to pass as
amended are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
the majority of the committee on
executive departments and administration
which is referred house bill 1171 fn an
act exempting certain niche beauty
services from licensure requirements
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with amendment representative
jennifer rhodes for the majority of the
committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate
representative
jackie wrote for the minority of the
committee
hello
for what reason does the memorize
i would like to make motion to table
the motion is to lay house bill 1171 on
the table are you ready for the question
[Music]
that might be representative burt
and it appears to be sufficiently
all right the question is whether to lay
house bill 1171 on the table
this is a roll call vote
representative the house will come to
order
representative grote is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know the house bill 1171
may put
the house in conflict with public
perception of public safety through
licensing
would i vote
representative osborne is recognized for
thank you mr speaker if i know that
occupational licensing reform is of
critical importance at this point in
time
and high in the mind of the public
consciousness would i now press the
the question is whether to lay house
bill 1171 on the table this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
156 having voted in the affirmative 189
so representative
we do not have a vote for you because it
appears you're not sitting in your
assigned seat so we need you to go there
and
if you're in the chamber you have to
156 having voted in the affirmative 190
all right
so we're still on house bill 1171 the
major the committee amendment is zero
eight four three h princeton page uh in
house record 108 on page 16.
the question is whether to adopt the
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted the question now is on the
majority committee report of ought to
pass with amendment the member from rye
representative grote is recognized to
speak against the committee report and
this is a one-on-one so don't go far
thank you mr speaker
house bill 1171 exempts certain duty
treatments
from licensure requirements by making it
makeup application eyelash extensions
that are currently done by licensed
individuals to be performed by anyone
this bill does not require as much as a
course in sanitation
infection prevention or passage of an
exam
this is out of step with all other
states
there are no states
that allow individuals to perform
cosmetic or beauty services without
minimum training or supervision by
licensed individuals
some states require a public posting
that those performing these services are
not licensed
this bill does not require this
stipulation
in the specific case of eyelash
extensions
a chemical is placed in the eye area and
the minority is strongly not in favor of
this allowance
there are no states that allow the
service without licensing and training
for the purposes of aesthetic or
cosmetic
the member from winchester
representative rose is recognized to
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker house bill 1171 fn will allow
a person to provide certain beauty
services such as blow dry styling
curling or arranging of a person's hair
or makeup application
some eyebrow services and last services
as well without having to have a
cosmetology or aesthetics license to do
so
these are services that most people
already do at home or have a friend or
family member do for them
currently new hampshire is only one of
ten states that is not exempt for some
of these services while every single
bordering state offers is at least at
the accepted services will not include
practices that involve hair the hair
coloring chemicals permian chemicals
hair cutting shears raises or any
specialty tools that require advanced
training
by the way a person is able to walk into
a store right now and buy at home hair
coloring and harm poem cuts i wouldn't
we heard in committee
one of the reasons not to pass this bill
was because if a person has an allergic
reaction or skin condition a
cosmetologist is trained to recognize
and diagnose that
that is illegal
a cosmetologist or an aesthetician is
not a doctor nor dermatologist both
being the same thing
they are not allowed to diagnose or
treat any conditions of the scalp or
allergic reactions
an example of someone that may choose to
own or operate one of these
establishments is someone that may have
had a cosmetology license at one time
however for any number of reasons does
not now
possibly a person that holds
certification and makeup application
another example is a person that has a
natural-born talent that they have honed
in over the years and decides to open a
business instead of paying for schooling
when their desire isn't to color cut or
perm a person's hair
mr speaker
the passing of hbill1117fn
promote entrepreneurship in new
hampshire by encouraging talented
and skilled individuals to supply work
for in-demand services without the need
to tackle themselves in bureaucratic red
tape and licensing laws thank you mr
speaker
maybe that was backwards but it was
effective representative barry requests
a world call which was preemptively
significantly seconded so this will be a
roll call vote members please take
receipts
okay the question is on the majority
committee report about to pass with
amendment
representative grote is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know
that
during the committee
hearings
eyelash extensions and the glue that is
used to
apply individual eyelashes to
current to existing eyelashes were the
issue that the minority had with this
bill
and this was an amendment that was not
entertained by the committee
would i now vote
red
representative mcguire is recognized for
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this bill removes
barriers to entry
for
services that are not commonly provided
in beauty schools
and if i know that nearly all of them
can be
performed
could be and in fact are performed at
home or by friends without danger
the skills are not
taught in beauty school so there is no
advantage to requiring licensure for
the questions on the majority committee
report have ought to pass with amendment
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the red green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
have all members present at an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
201 having voted in the affirmative 147
in the negative the committee report is
adopted
the majority of the committee on
executive departments and administration
which is referred house bill 1173 an act
proclaiming august 9th as indigenous
peoples day having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
tony lacus for the majority of the
committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same in being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative michael yakubovich
for the minority of the committee
the questions on the majority committee
report have been expedient to legislate
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
the majority of the committee on
executive departments and administration
which was referred to house bill 1330
and act relative to the board of
registration of medical technicians
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with amendment representative
michael yakubovich for the majority of
the committee
the minority of the committees having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment representative
william marsh for the minority of the
committee
the question is on the majority
amendment
zero three nine nine h princeton house
record 10 a on page 47.
the member from brookfield
representative marsh is recognized speak
thank you mr speaker
i rise today in opposition to the
majority amendment 0399-h to house bill
1330.
the majority amendment repeals the board
of medical technicians and ends the
registration of individuals who work in
medical fields and both have contact
with the public
and opportunity to divert opioid drugs
we would revert to the private sector to
prevent drug diversion and there is good
evidence that that has been ineffective
this board was established in 2016 in
response to the hepatitis c outbreak at
exeter hospital briefly a traveling
technician in the cardiac
catheterization lab was diverting
fentanyl for personal use
refilling drug vials with saline using
dirty needles and thereby contaminating
them with his own hepatitis c
public health tested 1074 patients who
had procedures
32 patients were identified with active
hepatitis c
identical to the technician's virus and
27 additional patients had evidence of
past hepatitis c infection but their
virus could not be tested
the individual involved was eventually
sentenced to 39 years in federal prison
for infecting 46 people in four states
with this deadly disease
he told his story to newsweek
and it was published as the cover story
confessions of a night shift junkie
in june 2015.
the u.s attorney for new hampshire
described him as a serial infector
newsweek quoted this technician as
saying
somebody has to tell how it's done
how easy it is and how the structure of
the hospitals isn't any good to stop it
he told how he hid his drug use
how he manipulated staffing agencies to
continue to get new hospital jobs and
how he was ultimately caught when the
hepatitis c outbreak occurred at exeter
hospital the last of the 19 hospitals in
eight states where he had worked
clearly the private sector was totally
ineffective in protecting the public
as a hospital trustee i know that i have
learned to suspect applications from
people who have moved from jurisdiction
to jurisdiction
and yet despite the testimony of the new
hampshire hospital association and
others the majority wants us to remove
this registration process that deters
serial infectors from applying for jobs
in new hampshire
new hampshire was the first state to
require registration of such technicians
and there have been no similar outbreaks
in the state subsequently
just by requiring registration we deter
most of these people who skip from state
to state one step ahead of the law from
applying to positions in new hampshire
according to the association of surgical
technologists as of now 12 states
require certification of surgical
technologists and three more besides new
hampshire require registration
i urge you all to defeat this amendment
so the minority amendment which would
continue to protect your constituents
and the public can be brought forward i
the member from hooksett
representative yakubovic is recognized
to speak in support of the committee
amendment
so the registration of medical
technicians is extremely rare in the us
and
in the existing structure we're already
talking about layers and layers of
institutions that oversee and work with
the technicians because technicians work
inside a hospital or inside a lab
i i want to we want to pass this
amendment the majority of the committee
because shifting of responsibility is
very dangerous faceless bureaucracy is
not going to help
much when when
there are already layers of people that
are responsible like the hospital
trustees the insurance corporation for
the hospital the hospital administrators
the doctors the nurses the staff should
see
who they hire and what they do to
patients they've promised not to do harm
and they'll and they fall back on the
bureaucracy to protect
uh their business
there's a break in the chain of command
and they should be responsible on what
happens to the patients that's why we're
repealing this unnecessary
it's holding us back from providing
better services the health care
facilities already struggling to hire
workers
and if we remove this barrier
uh
by eliminating registration in the field
we provide better service to the public
so please vote for the committee
representative marsh requested division
vote this will be a division vote
and it is sufficiently seconded this
the question is on amendment zero three
nine nine h
this is a roll call vote representative
marsha is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
mr speaker
if i know night shift junkies have been
discouraged from plaguing new hampshire
by the existing registration process
and if i know both hospitals and
confessed night shift junkies have said
the hospital vetting process is totally
inadequate to protect the public
and if i don't want another massive and
expensive outbreak of disease spread by
the dirty needles of night shift junkies
to affect my friends and neighbors would
i not press the red button and defeat
representative mcguire is recognized for
thank you mr speaker
if i know that the actions of one bad
actor
however heinous are not reason to
require thousands of technicians to
register and pay the fees
if i know that these technicians never
work independently but only under the
supervision of doctors and other med
health care professionals
and if i know that this creates an
unnecessary barrier
to health
to supplying employees to our health
care businesses would i not press the
the question is whether to adopt
amendment zero three nine nine h
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
this
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend the state of the
vote
175 having voted in the affirmative 168
the bill is on second reading and open a
further amendment representative marsh
moves amendment
06998 princeton house record 10-a
thank you mr speaker and i thank the
house for this opportunity to undo the
mis the
terrible thing we are doing to the
public with the amendment we just
adopted uh this minority amendment
replaces the bill with the minority bill
the board has been recently
dysfunctional due to its inability to
obtain quorum to do its duties
this
bill as amended by the minority
amendment would make it an advisory
board so that oplc can function
and the minority amendment ensures that
the advice the advisory board is
consulted whenever important decisions
need to be made i urge you to adopt this
representative mcguire is recognized to
thank you mr speaker i have to agree
with the previous speaker that
if you adopt this amendment you
completely undo what you did in the
adopting the majority amendment so i
would urge you not to not to waste
everyone's time by voting for it thank
you
the question is whether to adopt
nine amendment
are you ready for the question
division has been requested
representative not a request for roll
calls that sufficiently seconded there
it is
this will be a roll call vote members
the question is on amendment zero six
nine nine h
the member from brookfield
representative marshall is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
waves off all right
let's just do it
if you're in favor of adopting the
amendment you'll be pressing the green
button if you're opposed you'll be
pressing the red button voting stations
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
167 having voted in the affirmative 184
now we're on the majority committee
report of acha pass with amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes haven't the committee reports
adopted
the committee on executive departments
administration which was referred to
house bill 1357
and act relative to land acknowledgement
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolve that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative tony lakas for
the questions on the majority committee
report have been expediency legislate
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
they were names nobody asked for a
division
so i have to apologize to the house and
ask you for a favor
i know
i didn't see the second sheet and there
are people that were going to debate the
last bill instead i cranked through a
voice vote
so i would like someone to please
make a motion to reconsider the bill
and then have everybody vote yes so that
the people who signed up did the work to
representative graham is recognized for
a motion
mr speaker having voted on the
prevailing side i ask that we would
representative graham moves
reconsideration on house bill 1357 are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those opposed nay
[Applause]
i am in doubt that we did the right
thing so let's clarify it with a
the question is whether to reconsider
house bill 1357
representative marge smith is recognized
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know
that sometimes
we get tired and we aren't necessarily
paying attention
and if i know that we might have missed
the very serious and important request
from the presiding officer
that we reconsider
would i now vote yes
representative maguire is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that this
bill is a purely symbolic importance
would i not press the red button to not
reconsider
mr speaker my inquiry would be this i i
understand that you've said that you
that you made a mistake which is
completely understandable my question
would be
that if somebody if before the issue had
placed the issue as you had if somebody
had said i don't want to have a debate
let's just go vote would you have
allowed them to do that
all parties would have to agree
so doesn't that suggest to the body that
the request that was
was made by the by the speaker should be
granted that we should allow this to be
redone
i i appreciate you backing me up that's
not a real parliamentary inquiry though
thanks
i also be in order the question is
whether to reconsider
house bill
1357 this is a division vote
so
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
238 having voted in the affirmative 94
and the negative the motion passes thank
you
and i apologize to the house for my
what reason does a member rise make a
motion
state your motion i'd like to lay it
representative spelaine moves that house
bill 1357 be laid on the table
division has been requested this will be
the house will come to order
the question is whether to lay house
bill 1357 on the table representative
spelaine is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that we still have
a lot of work to do and i know how this
we all know how this one turns out
would i go ahead and push the green
representative goalie is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know we just
reconsidered our earlier vote so that we
could hear
this small debate
would i now press the red button so we
continue with the bait and get on with
the question is whether to lay house
bill 1357 on the table
that's a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
163 in the affirmative 178 in the
i said the house will be in order we're
finally getting to a debate that was
delayed by
a lot of stuff
the member from rye representative grota
is recognized to speak against the
committee report
in edna we hold hearings on bills
regarding
honoring specific events and causes on
first glance house bill 1537 appears to
be such a bill
and as you know those bills that come to
this house from the edna committee
often come with an itl
motion because among it is an agreement
among the members of the committee that
there are more productive options for
these requests
house bill
513-57 on land acknowledgement
asks for no
commemoration or fanfare
and this is not a simple bill
the subject diver deserves much more
than a quick look
house bill
recognizes that before there was new
hampshire
there was a land called andakana
and that the abernathy penacook and
wapanaki peoples a confederation of
indian tribes were a distinct people in
new hampshire
this land had the same mountains rivers
streams and forests
that we all hold precious today
this land remains magical and loved by
us all
this land is a continuum inhabited by
many people
and its history is important
regardless of who lived here or who
lives here today the natural beauty of
our state remains and is and is
protected and is protected
and is why many of us are here in this
house
i ask you to join me in overturning the
itl motion by voting red so that another
the member from hudson representative
tony lakers is recognized to speak for
thank you
so this bill would amend rsa1 concerning
the boundaries of the state of new
hampshire to acknowledge that there were
people here before us which is
not disputable
um
and while we're sure the sponsors of the
bill intended it just be a respectful
acknowledgement of the people who are
here before us
and to keep the people in new hampshire
aware of that history
there is concern about how that
acknowledgement might be construed in
the future while we understand the
sponsors and most of the supporters do
not intend this acknowledgement to
support possible land claims
we must always be aware of possible
unintended consequences of legislation
the statute created by the current
legislation will likely persist for many
years i mean it's rsa one which defines
the boundaries of this state
and even during our
committee hearing
we had at least one person who testified
and and uh
talked about restorative justice in the
context of this bill which was
concerning
and the other thing is we got uh
testimony from a tribal genealogist
who said that
there's conflict between groups of the
indigenous people in new york and canada
over how this should be handled
and
this person said it'd be best for the
state of new hampshire not to meddle in
that situation
so because of all that those reasons i
ask you to vote
green to support the itl motion thank
you
the questions on the majority committee
report have been expedient to legislate
on house bill 1357
division votes been requested this will
the house will come to order
and members please find your seats
the question is on the majority
committee reported venus speeding to
legislate on house bill 1357
the member from rye representative grodd
is recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that history
is important and that the legacy of our
the continuum of our land is also
important and if i know that there is an
amendment that was passed by the
committee that would refute any land
claims that this acknowledgement would
that this acknowledgement would not
recognize
would i now vote green
no
vote red to overturn i'm so sorry
to vote red on over attorney itm motion
thank you
the member from hudson representative
tony lakers is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
or representative maguire is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this purely symbolic bill
merely recognizes one group of
indigenous peoples
and if i also know that the other groups
of indigenous peoples in the state are
not pleased with it would i not press
the green button
to
keep us out of the out of that their
the question is on the majority
committee report i've been expedient to
legislator on house bill 1357 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you
will press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
183 having voted in the affirmative 151
on a negative the committee report is
adopted
the committee on executive departments
administration which was referred to
house bill 1510 an act establishing a
committee to study the hiring processes
used by state agencies having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolve that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
matthew santana for the committee
the question is on the committee report
of an expedient to legislate are you
ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
the committee on executive departments
administration which was referred house
bill 1560 an act relative to
non-resident licensure by the board of
barbering cosmetology and aesthetics
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass
representative jennifer rhodes for the
committee the questions on the majority
committee report about to pass are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
the house will be in
order majority committee on finance to
which was referred house bill 103 fn
enact establishing a dental benefit
under the state medicaid program
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment and
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass with amendment president of jess
edwards for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same to the an enabled
degree with the majority report the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislators in a bob lynn
for the minority of the committee
the amendment is
0904-h printed in house record 10-a
pages 2-4
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
question before the house
is the ought to pass with amendment
motion
are you ready for the question
roll call has been requested by
representative pratt is that
sufficiently seconded is sufficiently
house will be in order
the motion before us has ought to pass
with amendment
on house bill 103 fn this is going to be
a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative weiler
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that hb 103 passed the house on a
roll call vote of
225 to 127
and passed the finance committee on a
vote of 14 to 5. and if i further know
that this program will be financed by a
lawsuit settlement of 18 million dollars
so it will be not not added to our taxes
then would i now push the green button
in hopes that our medicaid population
will have improved health thank
you the motion before us is autopsies
and with amendment on house bill 103 fn
it's a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
approached press the red button voting
so
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
237 voting yay 100 voting nay committee
committee on finance to which was
referred house bill 1677 fn
and act relative to the administration
and the settlement of claims of abuse at
the youth development center and making
an appropriation therefore consider the
same report the same with the following
amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with amendment is in
amendment 0956h
printed in house record 10a pages 85
through 90.
the question is on the committee
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
committee amendments had adopted
bills on second reading opened a further
amendment
representative rogers and wallner offer
amendment one zero three eight h printed
in house record 10 a pages ninety
through ninety one
jr
recognizes
representative
long
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i'd first like to commend the
collaborative work with the attorney
general the victim's attorney and
especially the finance committee
i was quite impressed on the
collaborative
work that they had done uh
towards us this bill
this amendment adds emotional abuse i
i believe new hampshire has an
opportunity in addressing all
victimization done at the hands of our
facilities especially at minimum through
house bill 1677's process
all victims retain their right to choose
the court process however this process
ought to be available to all victims who
choose so
although the appropriation is an
extremely large allocation
i'm reminded of the tax dollars that
went towards perpetration of these acts
so i ask that you support
the victims
the victims of
in in this situation and we add all
victims
the opportunity to go through this
process
chair recognizer representative edwards
uh thank you mr speaker
i
i'd like you to understand just a little
bit of the process that got us here the
for the first time in decades the state
of new hampshire has stood up to the
plate and said
we are responsible and we are going to
be accountable for righting the wrongs
of many many decades where
kids that have been incarcerated in the
youth development centers
have been
warehoused to in a way in which
physical and sexual abuse seems to have
been
fairly cur common
and and too much of a part of the
culture that's what i'm hearing
anecdotally don't admit that into court
but that's what i understand
and so
what the a.g has done is
he and his office have set up
a settlement fund so that we can
efficiently process
hundreds of claims
and
the key claims that we must address are
the sexual
and physical abuse
like any project this is a this is a new
project
the biggest thing you need to worry
about is scope creep if you make the
scope too big
your project's going to fail
and so with a lot of thought
we and and debate we
are not
we don't want the emotional abuse
included in this bill which is what this
amendment does
because first of all emotional abuse is
very tough i think to adjudicate i think
just the mere fact that you're
incarcerated
legitimately would
feel like emotional abuse
and because it's it's it's messy and it
would open up
uh the settlement fund to
a a
scope creep that is
beyond what we're ready to do initially
and we may never get to that but
don't think
for a moment
that those kids who thought that they
were emotionally abused don't have
recourse there's always been a method
for them to file a complaint with the ag
and to have it adjudicated and that's
that avenue remains open to them what
we've done is we've set up a settlement
fund to officially process a large large
number of cases and i'd ask you to vote
against this amendment so that we can
allow the attorney general to focus on
the most egregious
claims
and get them handled as expeditiously as
possible thank you is the member yield
i i
represent i respect the representative
i'll take her question
member may inquire
thank you so much representative for
taking my question are you saying that
um watching a child
get raped by
a facilitator that facilitates this is
is less important and and should get
less rewards of damages than the one
that's actually doing the raping and is
getting threatened to
then be raped if they tell anybody
so i thank you for the question and i i
understand your concern to be
whether or not rape would be included
i'd say rape is part of the sexual
assault and that and that's clearly the
major reason we're doing this is to
um
adjudicate and and pay out and try to uh
compensate for their pain and anguish
the the monies that would help them deal
with the rape
so remember hopefully that answers your
question and i think we're done
does the member yield to further
questions
no member does not yield
a division has been requested members
the motion before us is the floor
amendment 1038-l
h
chair recognizes representative walner
if i know that this amendment will
strengthen this very very important bill
and if i know that this amendment
will add
emotional abuse in the definition of
child abuse
and if i know that research shows
that emotional abuse and solitary
confinement can cause lifelong damage to
young children
and young adults
and if i know for this settlement
process to work
the process must be viewed as inclusive
and open to all claimants
chair recognizes representative umberger
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that emotional abuse
child endangerment
false imprisonment
unlawful confinement
child exploitation
or deprivation of education
rights are issues that should be
considered
but should not be added to the
definition of sexual abuse or physical
abuse
would i now press the red button
and vote no on this amendment thank you
the motion before us
is floor amendment 1038-h
it is a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
imposed you'll press the red button
me
mr speaker if all members president had
an opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
164 voting yay 177 voting nay floor
houses
the bill is on second reading open to a
further amendment
the chair recognizes representative
thank you mr speaker
um i want to start out first of all
by in telling you that in the spirit of
bipartisanship with the member will
suspend for a minute until we get the
thank you mr speaker
and first of all in the spirit of
bipartisanship with which this bill was
written
i have to thank the member from
londonderry for the hat that i'm wearing
today which is the u.s marine corps hat
so i'm sure you can all tell which
member from londonderry and i hope that
in light of that he'll listen to what i
say and vote with me
house bill 1677 is amended is a great
start
okay
but
we can act now to make it an even more
effective response to a critical
situation
amendment 1022h will help to do that
according to the department of children
and family services director from 1990
to the present
four thousand seven hundred and seventy
six children were housed at the sununu
youth center and its predecessor
they've already there have already been
close to 500 cases of abuse filed in the
courts
and that number could increase
as a former county attorney this
situation resonates with me it's clear
based on the number of cases filed
against the state that the financial cap
on settlements in this bill is
artificially low at 1.5 million it
should be increased to 4.5 million
this is a significant increase but
there's a cause to do this from a legal
standpoint
the state by taking complete custody and
control of these children had a
fiduciary duty to them we promised to
provide the highest standard of care
if this case goes to civil court
all the plaintiffs have to prove by a
preponderance of the evidence which is
50.1 percent likelihood
is that the abuse happened
as lawmakers we must be prepared to
respond to several judgments against the
state of new hampshire
keep in mind
the state has already indicted 12 former
employees and promises to indict more
these employees account for the abuse of
close to one half of the child victims
and the state believes it can prove the
defendants abuse these kids
beyond a reasonable doubt a 98 percent
likelihood
for our purposes this means these cases
will either be settled and receive a
financial award from this fund that we
are creating or the cases go to trial
the plaintiffs have several lawyers
already committed to working these cases
on behalf of the child victims so far
the attorney general has won
it's entirely possible that if any of
these cases or several of these cases go
to trial that when jurors hear what
happened to these children
multi-million dollar verdicts in single
cases will result
it's critical to note some of the cases
in federal court in recent years
exceeded 20 million dollars even for
incidences less brutal than child rape
the federal court draws from a similar
jury pool as our state superior court in
merrimack county where these cases would
be heard
you have to anticipate the same jury
pool will yield similar outcomes
it's in the state's best financial
interest to agree to a process that will
resolve all or almost all of these child
victim cases as expeditiously as
possible
with as little additional trauma to the
victims as possible
after all it's the right thing to do
amendment 1022h expands the cap on
settlements to 4.5 million a more
realistic cap on settlement amounts
if we want the plaintiffs to come to the
table with their claims and avoid going
to civil court where 10 million or
higher dollar claims could result we
must be realistic about the logical and
likely financial risks
we should increase the cap the state is
willing to award in this process
i ask that you join me
in more properly compensating any
victims of abuse while in the state's
custody please support amendment 1022-h
by voting yes and pressing the green
button thank you mr speaker
do you recognize the representative
hamburger
thank you mr speaker
sorry
the cap in 10
is 1.5 million dollars for sexual abuse
and 150 thousand dollars for fiscal
abuse
these caps were set
as a result of the ag
looking out across the country
for
what settlements were out there
sexual abuse
and physical abuse
and that was the number
that
the dollars
that the ag came to us with as what was
the
i don't want to call it the average
settlement because it wasn't necessarily
adding up the figures and coming up with
a number it was looking at all of the
cases that were out there
now
as the representative from concord said
you don't have to choose the process
that we've put together
is designed as a
trauma
and victim-centered
process
as opposed to going to court
which is not necessarily
a victim or trauma
centered thing
but
this
the cap that we have put in the bill
i believe will actually
solve
all of the problems
that
were caused and i would agree
that these are absolutely horrible
to think
that this was going on
in our youth centers
over a long period of time
and
it was only recently
that the ag
in his
work discovered the horrific nature of
what was going on
so i ask that you vote red
and keep the caps that are currently in
1677 of 1.5 million
for sexual abuse and 150 000
for fiscal abuse thank you mr speaker
the motion before us
is on floor amendment 1036 h
this is going to be a division vote
so
the motion before us
is floor amendment 1036-h
this is a division vote chair recognizes
representative walner for parliamentary
inquiry
mr speaker if i know this amendment will
also strengthen this very important bill
and if i know the intent of this
legislation is to provide an alternative
for claimants to settle their cases
through the settlement fund process
as opposed to taking
cases to court which is a must much more
costly
set process for the state and for the
victim
and if i know
that the cap on settlement is too
if it is too low
claimants will choose court over going
through the settlement fund process
and if i know this amendment raises the
cap
to a more realistic level which will
encourage claimants to use the
settlement process
chair recognizes representative wilder
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know
that the attorney general made a
thorough study of rewards for sexual
abuse attacks on children by authorities
and that study led to a proposal
to create a settlement fund of 100
million dollars to use in a new system
to avoid going to court
if the damaged parties accepted it and
if i further know that the attorney for
the approximate 500 litigants kept
trying to increase the caps on the
settlements offered and if i know that
increasing the caps or the allowed
damages will make even that huge sum be
insufficient would i now press the red
button to keep from making this effort
unworkable thank you mr speaker
the motion before us
is the floor amendment 1036h
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed to press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
if all members president had an
house will attend to the state of the
vote
165 voting a 184 voting a
the amendment fails
we're back to the
original bill
with the committee amendment
so the emotion before risk has ought to
pass as amended
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
are you making a motion
what is your motion i'd like for the
previous debate to be printed would you
i'd like for the previous debate to be
printed in the permanent journal without
objection the motion is to replace
replace the debate in the permanent
all those in favor of
placing the debate in the permanent
only those in the room are allowed to
vote a division has been requested
also come to water
the motion before us is to print the
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you will
press the red button voting stations are
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
the house will attend to the state of
under an 88 voting a 155 voting a marks
majority of the committee on fish and
game and marine resources to which was
referred house bill 1091
act relative to search warrants for
individuals engaged in fish and game
activities considered the same report
the same they recommended that the bill
be referred for interim study as an
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved there's an
expedient to legislate but some larry
laflin the minority committee
the question motion before us is the
committee report of interim study are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
before we go on to the next bill
i just want to let everybody know what
the
plan is the food will be delivered about
5 30. it should be all set up and ready
to go for six o'clock
so we'll take a break at 6 o'clock
for hopefully about 45 minutes
we're asking you to go down to the
cafeteria that's where we'll be set up
again
and then come back here as soon as
possible so that we can hopefully get
another couple hours in
majority of the committee on fishing
game and
marine resources to which was referred
house bill 1297 and act relative to
taking lobster while engaged in
recreational scuba diving
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with the
is in james blaine for the minority of
the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator
katherine harvey for the minority of the
committee
the amendment is zero one five seven h
printed in house record 10a pages 46-47
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say
aye those opposed may
the eyes have it an amendment is adopted
the question before
the motion before us now is ought to
pass with amendment
on house bill 1297 i division has been
[Music]
the house will come to order members be
the motion before us is the majority
report of auto passes amended on house
bill 1297
this is a division vote the chair
recognizes representative aeger for
eagan
my mistake representative egan from
sugar hill mr speaker that's okay it's a
long day thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that the best way
to protect new hampshire's precious
lobster stock especially female
egg-bearing lobsters and support
economically important lobstering
industry in new hampshire is the only
way by highly using highly professional
career seasoned and easily regulated
lobstermen to catch these valuable
creatures and if i believe that personal
hand catching of lobsters by individual
scuba divers with limited experience
will complicate the monitoring and
regulation process of the already
overburdened marine patrol officers of
our deer fish and game department and
furthermore if i believe that the safety
of divers will be diminished as their
ability to handcut lobsters will most
likely take place where lobster stocks
reside therefore creating risk to divers
entangling themselves in the nets trap
lines and other dangerous gear that our
lobster industry uses would i now vote
no on house bill one two nine seven so
the better motion could be made thank
do you recognize the representative reid
for parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker mr speaker if i know that the
state directly to our south does allow
scuba and free divers to harvest small
amounts of lobster for personal use and
they have had zero issues with
enforcement zero issues with safety and
zero issues with conflicts between
divers and lobstermen and if i know that
none of the usual pro-conservation
pro-animal groups opposed this bill at
all but in fact the main opposition in
committee was a long line of people
representing the professional lobster
industry who stand to lose the high
dollar demand on their product if
individuals have access to sustainably
harvesting small amounts for personal
use as they do with fish and if i know
that one of the most preeminent wildlife
biologists in the state who almost
always is in committee supporting
data-based restrictions on take was
passionately supportive of this bill and
in fact debunked the myths that divers
cause damage when harvesting sustainable
amounts would i now press green and
the motion before us is the majority
report of autopass has amended on house
bill 1297
members need to be in their seats
so
the motion before us is the majority
port of auto pass as amended in house
bill 1297 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you press the green
button if you're opposed you press the
red button voting stations are open for
representative
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
under 97 voting yay
so
majority of the committee on fish and
game and marine sources to which was
referred house bill 1356
act relative to the taken of grey
squirrels having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with amendment
senator timothy lang from the majority
of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered to save me an unable to agree
with the majority report with a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass presenter ellen reed from the
what reason does a member rise
for emotion state your motion i move to
table
it is a proper motion the motion before
house bill 1356
we have a request for a division i heard
it will this will be a division vote
members take your seats this is a
the motion before us
is to table house bill 1356
the chair recognizes representative
andrew bolden for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that i sponsored this bill would i
the chair recognizes representative lang
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know the committee listened to two and a
half hours of conversation and public
debate about lactating gray squirrels
and further mr speaker if i know that
the amendment was adopted with
bipartisan support and the underlying
bill was ultimately adopted with
bipartisan support would i now vote red
the motion before us is a table house
bill 1356
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
156 voting yay 182 voting
so the debate is just
so it's going to be a division
right we're going right into a division
vote so members stay in your seats
we're going to be
doing just pis on the amendment the
amendment is 0 1 6 6 h printed in house
record 10a page 53
this is going to be a division vote
representative leflam for a
mr speaker if i know that rsa 207 colon
requires that the executive director
of the new hampshire fish and game
department
after consultation with the new
hampshire fish and game commission
through their rulemaking authority
shall have the authority to open and
close seasons for all small game
including grey squirrels
and mr speaker if i know that open and
closed hunting seasons for garyus for
various game species
are managed after consideration
on the advice of research of wildlife
biologist
and mr speaker if i know that this
amendment requires the executive
director
to permit gray squirrels to be hunted
year round
rather than during an open or closed
season like other
species of small game
and finally mr speaker
if i believe that new hampshire wildlife
should be managed through the advice of
wildlife biologists
rather than the whim of the legislators
then would i push the red button and
vote no on this amendment so another
motion could be brought to the floor
chair recognizes representative lang for
thank you mr speaker mr speaker i know
that i listened to two and a half hours
of testimony about lactating ray
squirrels and mr speaker if i know that
after hearing all of that conversation
with both the new hampshire farm bureau
with the forestry division with the fish
and game and many citizens that
testified that i came away with a
completely different opinion as well the
majority of my committee that these
animals
have uh they are the only rodent to have
a season other than the beaver and mr
speaker would i now vote to allow an
open season and the amendment to go
forward on grey squirrels
and
push the green button
the motion before us is the ought to
pass as amended motion on house bill one
the majority amendment on house bill
one three five six
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
o'hara
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote the house will
194 voting yay 147 voting a
the motion before us now is the majority
committee report of ought to pass has
amended on house bill 1356
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it committee report is
adopted
the house will be in order members take
your seats we have a one-on-one debate
majority committee on health and human
services and elderly affairs to which
was referred house bill 1022
an act permitting pharmacists to
dispense the drug
ivory mechtin by means of a standing
order having considered
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment is an elia cushman
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution that is inexpedient
to legislate of gary merchant for the
minority of the committee
the amendment
the amendment is
0-9-6-4-h printed in house record 10-a
pages 5 and 6.
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it an amendment is adopted
the chair
recognizes representative knurk to speak
thank you mr speaker
permitting a pharmacist to dispense a
medication by a standing order requires
a well-evaluated protocol established
through a broad consensus of providers
and pharmacists using the best available
data but a broad consensus supporting
the use of ivermectin and covet 19 does
not exist
the majority report claims that
ivermectin has been shown to be helpful
in reducing the severity and duration of
covet 19. but this is not true
there have been numerous studies
regarding ivermectin and cobot 19 which
sound compelling
but upon analysis have design flaws i
have personally reviewed many of these
studies
most studies so far are limited by
primarily by non-blinding or no
randomization but also by two small
sample sizes the use of concomitant
medications that confound the assessment
or poorly defined study groups and
outcome measures
and even the well-designed studies
still have significant limitations such
that definitive conclusions regarding
the clinical efficacy of ivermectin in
the treatment of cova 19 cannot yet be
reached
this is not
an issue of censorship
it is simply subjecting these studies to
the same robust analysis which must be
given to any study
internationally recognized independent
groups with decades of experience
analyzing studies such as the cochrane
group have determined that the few
studies of high quality which do exist
do not support the use of ivermectin for
treatment or prevention of covet 19
except
in ongoing well-designed clinical trials
this is not to say that ivermectin is
not a good drug
it is excellent for the treatment of
parasitic worms and has been around for
a long time and used well for that
purpose
the minority already worked with the
majority to allow off-label use of
ivermectin so that it can be obtained if
desired
standing orders with pharmacists should
not be used to dispense medications for
indications which are not clearly
supported by the best available medical
evidence
ivory mechton unfortunately at least as
of now does not yet reach this level of
evidence so please press the red button
to vote no so that another motion can be
the final speaker is coming up a roll
call has been requested by
representative blazik is that
sufficiently seconded
it is officially seconded this is going
to be a roll call vote members take your
seats
the chair recognizes representative
cushman
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker this bill is amended would
ensure granite staters have access to an
fda approved medication that has a drug
safety
profile better than tylenol
a standing order is a prescriptive
protocol written by a physician or nurse
practitioner that allows a pharmacist to
dispense a medication without an
individual prescription
the prescriber writes a protocol that
includes dosage and screening for
contraindication the patient receives an
information sheet
that informs them of adverse effects
indications and referral information
currently in new hampshire one can go to
a pharmacy and ask for hormonal
contraceptives and narcan via a standing
order
these drugs both carry substantially
more risk than ivermectin
ivermectin has been used in humans for
parasitic infections for over 30 years
effective in reducing severity of
symptoms of covid19 and other viral
illnesses is one reason people are
willing to go to great lengths to obtain
it
from purchasing abroad to purchasing
ivermectin formulated for animals people
will do what they need to do to get
their hands on this drug
when they are their loved ones are sick
they'll do what they have to
another reason is that unfortunately
medicine is becoming increasingly
politicized
consensus on the best protocol for
ivermectin but we do have many
well-established protocols that
physicians who write these standing
orders can reference and use
because of this politicization doctors
are afraid to prescribe and pharmacies
are afraid to dispense
if we pass this bill patients will have
access to the safe inexpensive generic
fda approved medication
that is created in fda regulated and
inspected facilities formulated for
humans
this will reduce the potential harm of
obtaining medications abroad and using
ivermectin formulated for animals and
could potentially mitigate the severity
of covid19 and other viral illnesses
we make experimental vaccines that have
had no long-term safety studies with
growing evidence of harm available at
pharmacies without a prescription and
claim it's because it could save lives
ivermectin has had over 30 years of
study showing that it is safe
and more and more evidence is surfacing
that it is effective permitting it to be
dispensed via a standing order could
save lives please vote ought to pass as
the motion before us is the majority
report of what to pass as amended
this is going to be a roll call vote
the motion before us is the majority
report of what a passes amended on house
bill
1022 this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative knurk
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that
permitting a pharmacist to dispense a
medication by a standing order requires
a well-evaluated protocol
established through a broad consensus of
providers and pharmacists using the best
available data and that the lack of that
consensus is not a political issue but
because of data which is insufficient in
the studies
and that only a few have are actually
being done at this point a few standing
orders and if i know that the fda fda
approval is for its indication of
treating parasites
not covet 19
and if i know that a broad consensus
supporting the use of ivermectin and
cova 19 does not exist
and that ivermectin can be obtained off
label once we've finished getting that
other bill through
would i then press the red button to
vote no
so that another motion could be brought
forward thank you mr speaker
do you recognize the remnant mark
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that ivor mecton is
already available over the counter in
many countries
and if i know that ivermectin is safe
safer than some of the over-the-counter
medicines we can presently buy here in
new hampshire
and if i know that some people unable to
get ivermectin over the counter here
have been resorting to going to farm
stores and getting it as it is
formulated for livestock and not for
people
and finally if i know that the choice
for ever so many people is not the
choice of ivermectin or vaccines
but ivormectin versus
nothing
and while it might not cure you
it's not going to hurt you
would i now press the green button to
give new hampshire people this freedom
the motion before us is the majority
report of auto passes amended on house
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you oppose you press the red button
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
180 house will be in order 183 voting
yay 159 voting a the committee report is
adopted
i request members stay in your seats we
have another request for a roll call on
this coming bill majority committee on
health and human services and elderly
affairs to which was referred house bill
an act relative to policies required for
health facilities and special health
care service licenses consider the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate
presenter jerry canurk from the majority
minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
with the following amendment and
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment sim jim callfall
from the minority of the committee
the chair recognizes
thank you mr speaker i rise in support
of house bill 1044 and in opposition
to the committee recommendation of itl
house bill 1044
would make a small but meaningful change
in our state statute governing the
licensure of health care facilities
in 2016 this legislature added a
provision to that statute
requiring that licensed health care
facilities must serve all patients
house bill 1044 would exempt certain
facilities from that provision
specifically it would exempt
organizations that operate on a
membership-based business model
or a direct payment business model
meaning that
the key concern raised in the majority
committee report
is that this bill would have an adverse
in fact the provisions in question were
added to statute in 2016.
we had critical care hospitals before
that
and if this bill passes there's no
reason to believe we will not have
critical care hospitals after that
furthermore critical care hospitals are
already protected by a 15-mile exclusion
zone
preventing the opening of new
they also receive favorable medicare and
medicaid reimbursement rates based on
their
protectionism
never leads to efficiency
it never
leads
to cost savings
and it never spurs innovation
free markets do
many of you may be old enough to
remember when
making a long distance phone call
was a little bit expensive
talking to family members in other
states often
involved keeping one eye on the clock
making sure you weren't talking too long
deregulation did wonders for the
telecommunications industry
it led to better service
lower prices
more options for consumers
and more innovation
widespread use of technology embracing
free market innovation should be allowed
this bill would open a modest window of
opportunity
that will lead
to better services
lower costs and innovation in our health
care system
i ask you to please join me in opposing
the committee recommendations so that an
alternate motion can be brought
representative blazik has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
we're down to our final speaker it is
sufficiently seconded this is going to
be a roll call vote members take your
seats
the chair recognizes representative
kanerg
thank you mr speaker
yes currently licensed healthcare
facilities are required to provide
services to all persons regardless of
the source of payment that requirement
was added in 2016 by the legislature to
ensure access to services for low-income
individuals and those covered by
medicaid
hb 104 would exempt health care
facilities which exclusively provide
services on the basis of direct payment
from this
uh from this requirement and that's
without any reimbursement from a third
party
or any insurance and so it actually it's
been billed as something to help you
with your high deductible but it really
won't because that bill has to be sent
through the insurance company in order
to be credited to your deductible
now such a change would allow a small
number of for-profit institutions
offering urgent care
birthing services
ambulatory surgery or other services
to skim off the high paying patients who
can pay the full cash price
and that changes the payer mix for
remaining hospitals
and that 15 mile exclusion doesn't make
much difference i live 15 miles from any
health care facility maintaining the
payer mix is important for those
remaining hospitals
our critical access hospitals run on
razor thin margins
and they lose money on services such as
the full-service 24-hour per day
emergency room and obstetrical services
which serve many people on medicaid or
with no insurance
those services which are critical to
have in rural areas are subsidized by
the higher paying services
and the higher paying insurances
skimming off the higher paying patients
would have a significant negative
economic effect on our critical access
hospitals
there will be a substantial risk of
hospital closure or the need to drop
clinical critical clinical services such
as maternity and we've seen that happen
leaving large numbers of individuals
especially in rural areas with no access
for timely medical care for emergencies
or for child birth
and the losses sustained by those
facilities will be shifted to those who
have insurance
driving up the cost for everyone else
and not changing that total
health care costs
the hospitals recognize the threat of
this bill to the existence of our
hospitals
and the need of all the hospitals to
share the burdens equally
the new hampshire hospital association
testified against this bill stating that
it will not benefit patients access nor
will it improve competition
the majority believes that this bill
will decrease access to health care and
will not drive down the overall cost of
health care
i also find it interesting that the
minority has said that this
helps the free market but it's
interesting because it only makes this
exemption
for certain business models that's not
the free market the free market would
not say
this group is exempted from this
requirement but this group has not
that isn't the free market
so i would like you to please press the
green button to support the committee
recommendation of itl
[Music]
the motion before us is the majority
report have been expedient to
legislative and health bill 1044. this
the motion before us is majority report
of index meaning to legislator in house
bill 1044 this is a roll call vote the
chair recognizes representative cushman
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that our current
medical system is broken
and patient satisfaction is at an
all-time low
and if i know that we need alternative
options for consumers and health care
workers
and further if i know that competition
and open markets promote the best
service at the best prices would i now
please press the red button so another
gee i recognize the representative
connerk for parliamentary inquiry thank
you mr speaker so if i know that our
critical access hospitals run on razor
thin margins and they require a payer
mix that includes private pay in order
to maintain the revenue losing services
such as 24-hour full-service
emergency rooms and obstructionable
services which are critical particularly
in our rural areas
and if i know that skimming off those
higher paying patients would have a
significant negative economic impact on
our critical access hospitals leading to
closures
of obstetrical services
and of critical access hospitals which
are needed to provide timely care in our
rural areas
and if i know that this bill will
decrease access to health care and will
not drive down the cost of health care
and if i know that this bill
is actually thinly veiled protectionism
for facilities that use just one
business model
would i then press the green button to
vote yes to support the 14-7 committee
the motion before us is the majority
report have been expedient to legislator
and house bill 1044
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
your opposed should press the red button
so
[Music]
do you want to change the outcome of
this
how's that
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attain to the state of the
vote
first
the motion fails
for what reason did the member rise i
move out to pass on hp 1044
yes sorry with the minority amendment
so we'll ought to pass with the with the
the minority amendment is 0991
h printed in house record 10a page 8.
for what reason did this member rise
for a motion mr speaker
state your motion i move to lay the bill
that is a higher motion
the motion
requested
somebody
representative blasic requested a roll
call that is sufficiently seconded this
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1044
this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
mr speaker
if i know what i've already said about
the fact that this is going to be
harmful to our critical access hospitals
and while it is true that they
did survive prior to this
uh
requirement 2016 it's important to know
if any of you have been dealing with
your hospitals you know
that their survival is rather tenuous
and a lot of hospitals have closed
and if i know that skipping off these
higher pay patients would be a problem
and that this bill again is a
protectionist bill for a small
business model
and will harm others because they're not
subjected to the same
suspension then i would would i then
vote yes to table this and not go any
further
do i recognize representative leon for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i believe it's wrong to hold some
patients captive just so that we can
have a certain patient mix
and if i believe some patients want more
than the allotted time from the
insurance companies so that they can
more thoroughly discuss their treatment
options with their patient with their
doctor
and come to a decision where they are as
the payer are the one in charge
would i then press the red button so we
the motion before us is to lay house
bill 1044 on the table this is a roll
call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
nope
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
166 voting yeah 179 voting a the motion
we're back to the question
on the amendment
i'll read it again
zero nine nine one h printed in house
record 10 a page eight
are you
are you ready for the question on the
amendment
a division i believe i heard a division
a division has been requested members
roll call has been requested by
representative bill disarro it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
house will be in order members in your
seats
the question before us is the amendment
minority amendment
to house bill 1044 this is a roll call
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're a pros you'll
press the red button voting stations are
so
[Music]
head if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
333 voting yay 10 voting nay the
is
the minority report of what to pass as
amended on house bill 1044
are you ready for the question
those opposed nay
[Applause]
i i put the hammer down before it was
definitely it was it was definitely
for what reason does the member rise
for a motion mr speaker
state your motion i move that we lay
house bill 1077 on the table and request
i haven't i haven't read it yet
representative
move things along
a little premature
majority of the committee on health and
human services and elder faith the
witch's referred house bill once
1077 an act repealing a prohibition on
conversion therapy for minors having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment senator mark pearson
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and be an enabled
degree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislators of joe
shapiro from the minority of the
committee
for what reason does a member rise for a
motion mr speaker
state your motion i move to lay hb 1077
the motion before us is the table house
a division has been requested
members take your seats
representative bell disarro requests the
roll call as that's officially seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is delay house bill
1077 on the table
this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes
joe alexander for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know the ban on conversion therapy was
recently signed into law in 2018 just
four years ago
and mr speaker if i know that according
to the trevor project lgbtq youth who
were subjected to conversion therapy
reported more than twice the rate of
attempting suicide in the past year
compared to those who are not
and mr speaker if i also know that any
attempt
to clarify the ban is an attempt to roll
the ban back would i then press the
green button to table hb 1077 thank you
mr speaker
the chair recognizes representative mark
pearson for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i also know conversion therapy as it
has been defined again and again in my
committee is bad
and if i know that the
amendment
significantly rewrites the bill to make
it compassionate and fair straight
across the board
and if i know that i have received
numbers of emails from people in the gay
and transgender communities who have
thanked me for this compassion would i
not want to
hear about this amendment this bill
so would i not suggest we press the red
button and not table it thank you mr
speaker
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1077
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
mr speaker
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
197 voting yay 147 voting a
majority of the committee on health and
human services and elderly affairs to
which was referred house bill 1080 act
relative to the rights of conscience for
medical professionals having considered
the same report the same with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass senator mark pearson from the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same would be an
unknowable degree with the majority
report with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to rep
legislate represent of lucy weber for
the house will be in order
chair recognizes representative weber to
what this bill does
is it protects those who do not want to
participate in abortions or
sterilization or artificial
contraception
from any discrimination in the workplace
based on that decision
it's titled the rights of conscience for
medical professionals
now
i believe the rights of conscience
first
in this case
doctors and nurse practitioners already
have protection of the
ama code of methodologics
and most employers
make accommodation for those who object
secondly
which means that for those medical
professionals the bill is not needed
secondly let's look at the terms of the
bill
the definition of medical professional
is so broad
that it includes those
who
are
manning the reception desk
and those who clean the floor of a
surgical suite
it's basically everyone who works in any
the definition is so broad that someone
who wanted to act maliciously
could seek employment
at a reproductive health care center
and then
be hired and then assert their right of
conscience
and what would happen then
well despite not doing the job for which
they were hired
they could not be terminated
because the bill says that termination
constitutes discrimination
and what happens if you discriminate
[Music]
the bill creates a new right of civil
action
and the recovery against the health care
center
would be a minimum of ten thousand
dollars plus costs
even
if
the employee
was perhaps
asserting the privilege
wrongly
that's a lot of burden
but here's the part that i particularly
object to in this bill
all persons should have
a right to act in accordance with their
conscience
and sometimes that's difficult
people have lost their jobs over it
and in this case what we are doing is on
the one hand we are affording
an absolute guaranteed clear
easy way
for people who believe
in
one course of action
to act in accordance with their
conscience
they're protected
people who believe
that as a medical professional as an
active conscience
they must help
a woman who is
past 24 weeks
of a problem pregnancy
who is making the most difficult
decision she will ever make in her life
with the help of her family and her
medical professionals
those medical professionals are
currently legally forbidden
for acting in accordance with their
conscience
so
on the one hand we have people whose
consciences are protected
and on the other hand we have people
whose consciences
have a legal barrier
that is
just
wrong
i ask you to press the red button so
representative mark pearson has
requested a roll call we're down to our
last speaker is that sufficiently
seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this is
going to be a roll call vote members
take your seats we're down to the last
speaker
chair recognizes representative mark
pearson
conscience is a precious thing
i think most of us have seen the
documentaries about the unspeakable
things that doctors and their staffs
were forced forced to do in nazi germany
and yet one hears that in numbers of
states medical people are forced to
participate in a procedure that is they
and i understand it
is the taking of an innocent human life
there are numerous places where abortion
is practiced but as a small portion of
what is being done
this bill would allow persons of
conscience in this matter to keep their
jobs there not disrupting the facility
while allowing the member will suspend
it
member may continue
thank you mr speaker this bill would
allow persons of conscience in this
matter
to keep their jobs
while allowing others to stand in for
them in those procedures only
i've heard several objections to this
bill
first these protections are already
there in law
if that's the case then no one has
anything to fear for
us making it a bit more explicit do they
we're not adding anything we're just
making these protections that we're told
are already there in the law just a
little bit more explicit
it's an abundance of caution a phrase
we've all been using
second we've been told no medical
professional in new hampshire has ever
been put in job risk for that
you have not spoken to the people i have
next during the hearing
i was asked as prime sponsor of this
bill would i be willing to include other
medical procedures and other kinds of
professions
thank you to my colleagues across the
aisle for bringing that up my response
is over the summer i should be happy to
work with my colleagues in my committee
who pose these questions so we can file
some bipartisan lsrs
fourth
this bill is signed into law the
objections
say
would lead to a reduction in the number
of capable medical people coming to work
here in new hampshire and thus our
quality of care would suffer
we should discount such fear-mongering
the fact is for many years massachusetts
had a bill just like this actually with
tougher penalties and yet continued to
draw good people to practice medicine
and was consistently rated as having one
of high quality
i discovered that states with laws like
the one proposed here
have drawn many quite capable pro-life
medical staff maybe even we would get
better
for allowing such conscience here
and finally it was suggested that an
individual might join the staff of a
facility where abortion is the main
procedure performed and then once their
start asserting rights of conscience
it does not take much mental acuity to
know that no pro-life person would
choose to work at such a place
i close with a quote
about nazi germany
made by martin niemoller a german
lutheran pastor about how people of
conscience have to stand up for each
other even if their issues differ
these are the words that are found on
the u.s holocaust
memorial first they meaning nazis came
for the communists and i did not speak
out because i was not a communist
then they came for the trade unionists
and i did not speak out because i was
not a trade unionist
then they came for the jews
and i did not speak out because i was
not a jew
then they came for me
and there was no one left to speak for
me
the member will the member will suspend
a little bit
off base if we could bring it back to
people of conscience mr speaker need to
stand together and i ask people to stand
with me on this
because there may well be a time next
time when i'm being asked to stand with
the motion before us
is the ought to pat majority report of
how to pass
this is a roll call vote members take
the motion before us the majority report
of ought to pass on house bill 108-0
chair recognizes representative weber
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that our
constitution tells us that rights ought
to be reciprocal
and i know that to favor the rights of
conscience of one group of people
over the rights of conscience of another
group of people is just wrong would i
house will be in order
chair recognizes representative leon for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know an aspiring doctor nurse or
other health care professional has very
little say in what procedures they
participate in and no law to cite today
if they're asked to violate their
conscience by terminating what they
believe to be an innocent life
and if i know the potential care
providers decide early
when they decide to take pre-med classes
or not
what path they're going to go down and
we don't know how many future not just
nurses doctors and other health care
professionals don't enter this
profession because they're afraid that
they may have to violate their
conscience in this way
and if i know
if those tasks do no harm should not
have to undergo harm themselves in order
to do their job
would i then press the green button in
order to pass this bill
motion before us
is the majority report about to pass on
house bill 108-0
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor or press the green
button if you oppose you'll press the
red button voting stations are open for
so
[Music]
mr speaker if all members president had
an opportunity to vote
175 voting a 165 voting aid the
for a reason does a member rise
thank you mr speaker mr speaker i move
that the very prescient remarks of the
last debate be published in the
the motion is to publish
the remarks of the last debate in the
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
amendment the printed amendment pearson
majority of the committee on health and
human services and elderly affairs to
which was deferred house
bill 1180 an act relative to state
recognition of biological sex
we're considered the same report the
same with the following amendment
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment it's an authentic
acting for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution result that is
inexpedient to legislate senator jerry
cannon for the minority of the committee
the amendment is zero nine five nine h
printed in house record 10 a pages 17.
what reason does a member rise for a
motion
state your motion
i moved to lay house bill 1180 on the
table
well
you give me a minute to announce it
that is a proper motion
representative greeson
is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
members take your seats this is a roll
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1180 this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative cannon
mr speaker
over the past three years we have heard
a bill
represented this a parliamentary inquiry
if if i know over the past three years
we have heard similar bills
about transgender
people in sports
in the past two years
those bills have gone nowhere
because
if i know
that the transgender population and the
medical staff working with them
as well as our school systems and even
collegiate environment are making
changes to the policies
that allow transgender girls to work to
to play and to work with other
would you please vote with me
and table this
chair recognizing
representative mark pearson for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that 60 years ago
title ix
was put into law so that girls could
compete with boys women with men in a
much more equal way than they had before
and mr speaker if i know that we are
seeing an increased amount every time
this bill comes by there's more and more
and more cases
of champion girls who are now losing
to people
who as on mail teams
didn't win much at all
and mr speaker if i know that this bill
is
not telling schools what to do but
allowing them to have their local
decisions
would i now not
press the button against tabling thank
the motion before us is a tabling motion
on house bill 1180
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're approached you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
ball members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attain to the state of the
vote
167 voting a 169 voting a the tabling
which is
17. the chair recognizes representative
mark pearson to speak against
thank you mr speaker when this amendment
was first crafted it represented
knowledge
that we had
having spoken to correctional officials
and since then however we have learned
that in a few places around the country
certain laws have been put in place and
with that has come the kind of problems
that occur when fixed laws replace
flexible policies we want to preserve
what we have now in new hampshire with
our flexibility because one size does
not fit all
inadvertently the amendment will weaken
this we've just discovered this and so i
am strongly suggesting we vote no on
sam gould has requested roll calls
this will be a division vote
so
the question before us is the adoption
of the amendment zero nine five nine h
this is a division vote
the chair recognizes mark pearson for
thank you mr speaker and pardon me for
the confusion once again
my pi is if i know
that the amendment when we first put it
together was brilliant
and if i know subsequent knowledge that
has come to us have said that this could
be counterproductive
i would
would i not press the red button against
the amendment thank you mr speaker
the jail recognizes representative gay
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know the goal of this amendment is
to protect women's sports
and if i know this bill without the
amendment could allow carding
or blocking trans people from public
bathrooms
and if i know this bill without the
amendment could also complicate the job
of new hampshire corrections
who already must follow federal
under the prison rape elimination act of
are priya as they call it
and if i know that women and girls
participating in sports with trans women
teens and adults
deserve to compete against people whose
in transition started before they
reached male strength as advocated by
caitlyn jenner
then wouldn't i support this amendment
by pressing the green button
i request
the motion before us is the vote on the
amendment zero nine five nine h to house
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
representative
okay
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
the amendment fails
the question now is on ought to pass
they were
majority of ought to pass
the chair recognizes representative
tanner
you thought you were through with me
um thank you mr speaker
i guess they're coming for me
so this bill is all about discrimination
plain and simple
the few transgender children who
participate in sports
vary in athletic ability size shape and
as much as other youth do
some
youth have outstanding athletic ability
some not so much
gender identity shouldn't play a role in
the opportunities that we give students
in all activities and courses we offer
in school
including sports
there are governing bodies at all level
of sports competition that regulates
seasons rules
and eligibility to participate in sports
at our high school level in new
hampshire
it is part of the new hampshire
interscholastic athletic association
this association that oversees all high
school competition in the state
has concluded that it would be
fundamentally unjust
and contrary to applicable state and
federal laws
to preclude a student from participation
on a gender specific sports team
that is consistent with the public
gender identity of that student in his
his or her school
and community
local schools are charged with verifying
that the school district has determined
that the expression of the student's
gender
identity is bona fide and not for the
purpose of gaining an unfair advantage
in competitive sports
if you think a high school boy
would put on suddenly put on a skirt and
try out for a girls team
it doesn't just doesn't happen in high
school i taught in high school for 30
years
school sports at all levels
should be centered on inclusion
education and participation
there's ample evidence that an
opportunity for adolescents to
participate in sports
results in positive outcomes such as
better grades
better work in class
self-discipline
higher educational and occupational
aspirations and improved self-esteem
youth learn a lot of lessons in sports i
coached for many years
they learned to get better to have a
role on a team they learned
sportsmanship leadership
hard work
and they learn to be gracious in winning
and to be resilient in the face of
defeat which some of us could take a
little lesson on
um this is all discrimination
okay it's not about safety issue
i taught for a long time co-ed high
school physical education
and for over 30 years i had no concerns
with safety
it's not about co-ed competition
we had co-ed competition in in
classes and
there were as many girls that did well
as boys
it's not about fairness which is an
elusive term when your tallest
basketball player
on my team was five four and the other
team had a six foot center
because there will be differences and
not related to gender
identity it's not about winning and
losing
because eventually you meet some team or
person who will be better than you
ncaa and the olympic committee where
competition is a little bit higher
have other rules and regulations but
they also let transgender
people
identify and play in sports
as it so this bill is giving permission
to schools and governmental agencies
this bill to deny a young person the
ability to participate based on their
gender identity their authentic self
who they think they are
how they feel
and that is wrong to deny that
as a country as new hampshire we have
made
our
non-discrimination laws
a statement
that how
new hampshire treats people in protected
classes and transgender people are in a
protected class
i believe that discrimination is wrong
and that everybody should have the
ability to succeed in our public schools
and life
everybody don't come for them
thank you mr speaker
we had an amendment that took away
two-thirds of a very bad bill
but that failed so i'll tell you about
the two-thirds of the very bad bill that
remain
one of the things that
one of the areas that
people would be allowed to assign people
only to their biological sex if they
chose to do that
is in the prison system
and the rationale for that was
uh
transgender
women who had not completed their
transition being in prison with females
so here's the problem
what we should be doing for our prison
population is making sure that
absolutely everyone is safe
every single prisoner
we know that because we just had the
bill about the youth development center
we need to keep everybody safe
and the way of doing that is not
assigning somebody who is part way
through a transition from male to female
back to a male prison
that's not safe the other thing is that
it is not fair to put all the burden of
safety
on transgender people
what we ought to be doing in the prisons
is to ensure the safety of all the
prisoners
and that is being worked on with prison
policies
and
their policies of how people are housed
which takes into account and recognizes
their gender identity without forcing
them
to relinquish it
so that's we we had very strong language
from uh both i believe
somebody who is a superintendent of
corrections in one of the counties and
also from the department of corrections
at the state level
that this the provisions of this bill
are going to make their lives infinitely
more difficult
so that's one thing the other section
that's still in the bill
is the inclusion of what was called
you know what that sounds like to me
that sounds like a bathroom bill
do you remember what happened in north
carolina when north carolina passed a
bathroom bill
it wasn't pretty
people actually
pulled out athletic competitions and all
kinds of other things because they
had gone down that road
and i know that people are going to tell
me well this just permits people to do
it it doesn't require
but here's the rub with that
if you permit people to discriminate
in all three of these areas sports
prisons and places of intimate privacy
then
a transgender person who is assigned
unfairly
to a place
for their biological sex
will no longer have the protections
against discrimination
that they now have because we just
removed them in this bill
and there will be no recourse for them
so for those reasons
because this bill is now back to its
original and exceedingly flawed form
i ask you
to press the red button and it'll so
that another motion can be made thank
no remember it does not yield
so what is our purpose here
are we putting in legislation
to control a very small portion of our
population
our transgender population for everyone
is about one-third of one percent
of our entire population
of that
only about 500
members are students
most of those students
are there to get an education very few
of them are there to participate in
sports
and it's very rare when one of those
students
superstar i understand we have a need
to make sports fair between
transgender girls
our schools are aware of this
the agencies the the athletic
associations are aware of this
the ioc and the ncaa are aware of this
and they've been putting in
place policies
to help both the transgender
girls and the trent and the straight
they've
identified medication that allows
students
it allows people to block the hormones
of students
of young people
from
proceeding through puberty
these transgender girls who are taking
these puberty blocking drugs
grow at the same rate
as their girlfriends
in the community
they don't grow to be
most of these girls
won't start
estrogen therapy until they're 18 years
old
up until that time they won't have
testosterone in their system
they won't be growing
they won't have some of the impact as
far as their skeletal strength
and muscle muscular structure as other
boys
there are a number of organizations
that are defining what the policies are
for transgender girls in sports
first off in the school system
the
new hampshire school board association
has put policies in place for
transgender girls
to be
in school systems
edu to get an education just like
everyone else
they don't touch on
sports a sports area is left up to the
new hampshire into scholastic athletic
association
that association has defined
a rule that a transgender student that
wants to play in sports
needs to be registered as
a girl
or a boy depending on the gender they
identifies as at the beginning of
entering high school
with the full support of their parents
if they are participating in sports
on a girls sports team they have to stay
participating on a girls sports team if
they grow and they're participating on a
boys sports team they have to stay on a
boys sports team they can't cross over
between those
in the ncaa
they just released
[Music]
in february
policy
concerning transgender girls in sports
in the collegiate and inter
intercollegiate
uh environment
even the ioc
the olympic committee has
similar
policies these policies require
that a transgender athlete
has to start getting tested for their
testosterone levels so that they may
compete at the same level as other girls
that policy has just gone into place
and
it it's going to start with one test a
year and it's going to go next year to
two tests a year so they're going to
keep track of
the hormone levels to make sure they're
providing a safe environment for
transgender
girls or women and other women
these are only
a few of the organizations that are
working with the transgender community
to provide a level playing field for for
the environment in which they work and
this bill that's been introduced
is on the the bleeding edge
or the leading edge of what is already
happening in in other places and it's
if we implement this bill
it's ignoring
that this work is already being done in
other areas
and it may be more appropriate to be
done by other associations organizations
that are working with transgender people
rather than putting in something into
statute
that will negatively affect
future transgender
women
or transgender men
that are just trying to live their life
like everyone else
on a level playing field
please
vote
red on this bill thank you
does the member yield to questions
no
member does not yield
we're down to the final speaker this is
representative gould has requested a
for what reason does a member rise i'd
like to make a motion
we've had intervening business so the
motion is in order
you're
uh
we have a request
for a roll call by representative bel
disarro is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote on the tabling motion
the house will come to order
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1180
the chair recognizes representative
mullin for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that since the last
tabling motion this bill has changed
tremendously and that it now includes
safety issues in prison
privacy issues and bathrooms as well as
global discrimination issues
and if i believe that tabling this bill
sends a message to new hampshire
about
our position on discrimination would i
please press the green button
in favor of the tabling motion thank you
recognize the representative leon for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that ncaa and olympic
standards for transgendered athletes
require the recognition of biologic sex
in order to respect the rights of the
transgender athletes and those whom they
compete with and if i know that circuit
court rulings
have hinged upon whether or not the law
in a particular state recognizes the
state's role in recognizing biologic sex
in order to make these distinctions
would i then press the green button
sorry the red button thank you
sorry
would i then press the red button
in order to allow our state to continue
to recognize biologic sex so that we can
make sure that we are not discriminating
against people and we can recognize
their unique individuality
and their specific
the motion before us is the tabling
motion on h.b 1180
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
okay
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
175 voting yay 167 voting nay the
we're gonna we're going to the the
sandwiches
are all set downstairs
the new hampshire auto dealers
association has graciously stepped
forward to sponsor our meal option this
evening
let's take a moment to thank them
[Music]
we have a variety of sandwiches and
wraps from the works cafe in concord
downstairs in the cafeteria
we also have chips and cookies
again we ask you to only take one
portion at a time to ensure everyone
at least gets one and then go back for
seconds
important please enter the kitchen on
the side of the cafeteria to get your
food
then you can make your way to the dining
area members lounge or any other area
to each of your to eat your sandwich
having dinner is meant
to keep you here
majority of the committee on health and
human services and elderly affairs to
which was referred house bill 1347
and act relative to licensing
requirements for health care facilities
that operate on a membership-based
business model having considered the
same report the same with the following
amendment a recommendation to fill out a
password amendment
senator leah cushman for the majority of
the committee
minority of the committee
unable to have been considered the same
and being unable to agree with the
majority report with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
jerry connect for the minority of the
committee
for what reason does a member rise
for a motion mr speaker stage of motion
the motion is proper
the motion before us now
1347. are you ready for the are you
ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it
join the committee on health and human
services and elderly affairs to which
was referred house bill 1369
and act relative to covert 19 health and
safety policies at new hampshire
performing act venues considered the
same report the same with the following
amendment a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with amendment senator
jerry canert from the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
fall in resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate senator leah
cushman from the minority of the
committee
the chair recognizes representative
cushman
would like to make a motion
for what
stage of motion i would like to uh
motion to table 1369.
that is a correct motion
the motion before us is to toot
is to table house bill 1369 a division
has been requested members
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1369
this is going to be a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
blazik for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that there is nothing in statute
that currently prevents anything that
this bill seeks to codify
and if i know that we should not waste
our time on unnecessary legislation that
does nothing more than add new laws to
the books with no purpose
and if i know that performing arts
venues have been setting their own
coveted policies this entire time i
would now vote green to table this bill
g i recognize the representative kenner
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that
it is true that facilities of venues can
do this but they have been challenged
with people saying that you do not have
the right to set your own protocols
and them setting their own safety
protocols for the safety of their
patrons and for their employees
is a business decision which they should
be allowed to make on their own
and if i know that if they do not honor
the requests of the artist that artist
can take their business to another venue
perhaps across the border to a southern
state state just bordering us to the
south and we lose that business
and if i know that many patrons will
feel much more comfortable to go into a
setting if they do know that their
safety is being respected
and therefore it can be a marketing move
in addition to their own independent
business decision
and if i know that what this bill does
then is affirms
the firms the fact that they do have the
authority to set their own business
policies with regard to various
protocols for protection for
communicable diseases
would i then vote against this tabling
motion thank you
the motion before us
is table house bill one three six nine
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you press the
red button voting stations are open for
so
all remember as president had an
opportunity to vote
177 voting yeah 146 voting a house bill
for what reason is remember rise
we have nothing in front of us
yet it's to bring something up
i would like to motion to print the
remarks on house bill 1180
i'm sorry i do put the remarks in the
permanent journal which one for what
for house bill 1180
the motion is to put the remarks for
the motion before us is to print the
remarks
from the debate on house bill 1180 in a
permanent journal
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested members
so
the motion before us is to print the
remarks
of house bill 1180 in the permanent
journal this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you oppose you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
representative dolan
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
183 voting yay 150 voting a the marks
committee on health and human services
and elderly affairs to which was
referred house bill 1379
act relative to the department of health
and human services rule making authority
regarding immunization requirements
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment and
recommendation that the bill are to pass
with amendment
senator jim colfat for the committee
the amendment is 0 8 44 h printed in
house record 10a pages 54 and 55. are
you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it an amendment is adopted
question before the house now is on the
motion of ought to pass with amendment
on house bill
1379 are you ready for the question all
vision has been requested members take
who requested a roll call senator blasic
requests the roll calls that's
officially seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
are you doing a pi representative
representative
my apologies i forgot that i was not
number two wait what
not not yet
the motion before us is ought to pass
with amendment
the chair recognizes representative
canark
for a parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker if i know that this bill
removes the
authority of the commissioner of dhhs
to be able to add
by rule
various immunizations that may be
necessary to be done
and that's done very rarely it's only
been three over about 20 years the last
one was done in 2003 so it is not
something that is done
in a lighthearted fashion and if i know
that the commissioner doesn't do this
on their own but instead they do it in
consultation with
the epidemiologists many other people
and national guidelines
would i then vote against this bill so
that we could maintain the policy that
we have had
of having the commissioner have the
flexibility to be able to respond to
public health issues as needed thank you
jay i recognize representative leon for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that today childhood
immunizations are split between laws and
rules
and what this bill does as amended is to
provide a pathway so that all the
mandated vaccines will come to a vote of
the legislature
and if i know that this preserves a
pathway
for a one-time
permission for 20 months for anything
that is voted on and approved by the
oversight committee so that we can
respond to emergencies would i then
motion before us
is ought to pass with amendment on house
bill 1379 this is a roll call vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you oppose you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
[Music]
if all members president had an
house will attend to the state of the
vote
169 voting a 164 voting a committee
the majority of committee on health and
human services in elderly fiesta which
was referred house bill 1409 act
relative the age at which a minor may
receive a mental health treatment
without parental consent having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment sin lucy weber for
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator mark
pearson from the minority of the
committee
i rise to table the uh bill okay we
weren't i didn't know what you were
looking for so you make a motion to
table
senate pearson has made a motion to
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1409
the chair recognizes representative leon
thank you mr speaker
if we earlier today discussed how
vulnerable children are when they're
sitting in a therapist's office and we
respected that vulnerability
and if i know
that parents should be involved in the
therapy of their children and to at
least know if their child is seeing a
therapist
and if i believe that this interferes
with not only parental rights but family
relationships would i piss the press the
green button to table this bill
chair recognizes representative weber
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i agree that parents should be
involved but i know that there are many
parents who are either disengaged or
unable to engage and do not look after
their children
and if i know that by age 16 a child a
minor can consent to sexual activity
much as we wish they wouldn't
and to
be treated for a sexually transmitted
disease and tr and treated for drug
abuse and substance abuse
and if i know it makes no sense
to wait till a minor is addicted before
we give them help
so it would be better to allow them
mental health treatment where a
counselor might help them connect with
their family and repair the damage to
the family structure
would i now push the red button
to allow this bill which passed the
committee with a bipartisan majority to
go forward
the motion before us is the tabling
motion on house bill 149
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you opposed you press the red button
of all
the members president an opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
171 voting a
163 voting a
what reason to memorize to make a motion
state of motion i move to remove hp 1264
she wants some removal from the table
yep
pi against
a roll call has been requested is that
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
the motion before us
is to remove
the motion before us is to remove house
bill 1264 from the table this is a roll
call vote chair recognizes
representative reid for parliamentary
inquiry
okay
both have waived off
the parliamentary inquiries we'll go
right to the vote
if you're in favor of removing 1264 from
the table you will press the green
button if you're opposed you will press
the red button voting stations are open
representative
of all members president an opportunity
to vote
majority of the committee on health and
human services and elderly affairs to
which was referred house bill 1439
act relative to hospital visitation
policies having considered the same
report the same
with the following amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment president erica lay
on from the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment it's an elusive
weather for the minority weber for the
minority of the committee
majority committee amendment is one zero
two nine h printing and health record 10
a page 59.
are you ready for the question all those
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it the majority amendment
is adopted the chair recognizes
representative weber to offer minority
amendment
0946h printed in house record 10a page
60.
thank you mr speaker
we all agree
and we heard heart-rending stories and
all of us have life experiences that
lead us to the conclusion
that
everyone who is in hospital deserves the
support and care
of their loved ones
and we worked very hard on this bill and
we worked collaboratively on this bill
and
we came together on a lot of things so
i'm
i thank
the problem is that
what we didn't agree on first of all we
we agreed
that a policy should be in the patient's
bill of rights
that it should be the right of the
patient
to have their loved ones with them when
they're in a facility
and
we agreed that we would keep the
language from the original bill
that balances the rights
of one patient
to have the support and care of their
family or loved ones with the rights of
every other patient to also have
appropriate care
appropriate infection control
and appropriate support that they need
so
the bill contains a set of balances
that
the presence of visitors
medically and therapeutically
indicated
that the presence of visitors
will not interfere with the care of
others
that visitors engaging disruptive and
threatening or violent behavior can be
excluded
and visitors non-compliant with hospital
policy can be
included that's in both bills
that's the balancing that is important
here's where the bills
the amendments differ
in my amendment
those considerations are put just in the
patient's bill of rights
in the amendment you just passed
they are also put into the hospital
licensing the facility licensing statute
so
when
in the course of a terrible pandemic or
other
horrible emergency
the hospital has to balance these rights
and the amendment we just passed also
requires
that whenever a visitor is denied access
it must be carefully charted into the
medical records
so at a time when resources are scarce
and
risks are high
we are using valuable medical time to
deal with charting
instead of caring for patients
and at a time when hospitals are having
to make the most difficult of
dyscritical decisions
we are putting their license on the line
if they get it wrong so i believe
that the appropriate thing is to give
the rights to the patient in the
patient's bill of rights
protecting the rights of all patients
and simply leave it there
and adopt the minority amendment by
chair recognizes representative leon
thank you mr
speaker my colleague from walpole is
right that it is good to be able to have
patients have visitors it is good for
their health that is good for their
outcome and it is good for their family
members that don't know if they'll ever
see them again
in committee we heard people here in new
hampshire
they were unable to see their daughters
that were my age
and those daughters died of covet in the
hospital
it was worse
that nobody knew what to expect
you didn't know what the visitation
policies were
you couldn't find them you didn't know
what was going on
why you would be denied
and what was happening with your loved
one
the two differences we have are we put
it in the licensing statute with the
majority amendment that we've already
adopted
and we make it so that there'll be a
documentation so that we know why it's
been denied
it's easy enough to when you're saying
that the patient coded say the patient
coded and we asked the family to leave
it's a small change if you have a
significant medical event you're already
documenting it in the paperwork and this
protects both the patients and their
access to their family members and the
hospitals if somebody's aggrieved and
let's be honest these times are trying
we've all been trying to survive these
last two years with as little harm as
possible
if we stay if we defeat this amendment
and stay with the majority amendment
that we've already adopted
this they will have to have their
policies online and on the wall of every
patient room
so that when the patient is upset or a
visitor is upset if they have to leave
the provider can say right here i'm
sorry
but this is a risk to another patient's
rights and so we need to ask you to
leave
we'll have transparency we'll have
clarity
and we can move on with the business of
healing
so i ask you to vote against this
amendment and press the red button
does the member yield questions
yes member yields
thank you mr speaker uh thank you
representative for taking my question
this is something near and dear to my
heart as the chairman of veterans
affairs are you aware that here in new
hampshire we had family members outside
the va home knowing that their family
member had covert was dying and could
not go in would not let them wear a mask
they had to stay outside while they
remember died are you aware of that
i was thank you for the question i was
not aware of that happening at the va
but i know that that happened in many
the question before us the minority
amendment
who requested a roll call senator blazik
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us
is
the minority amendment zero nine four
six h
the chair recognizes representative
weber for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that no one is arguing that
people should be excluded
from supporting their loved ones and if
i know that the terms of these two
amendments are basically
the same
except for the extra burdens put on
a health care facility
at a time of emergency
when resources are scarce personnel is
scarce time is scarce
and
extra burdens
will result
in bad health outcomes to some of the
patients
would i now push
the green button to support this
amendment thank you
i recognize the representative layout
for parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker
if i know that the patient's bill of
rights already protects the right to
have a visitor
when death is imminent but that was not
always granted
and if i know that a law without teeth
is only a suggestion
and if i know
that while a large step putting this in
the licensing statute
may actually guarantee that the
hospitals are transparent about the
policies
the motion before us is the minority
amendment zero nine four six h
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
the walmart mr president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
158 voting a 177 voting a minority
now the question is on ought to pass as
amendment
for house bill 1439 the chair recognizes
representative leon waves off
the question now before us
is
the ought to pass has amended motion
majority emotion
on house bill 1439
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say
aye those opposed nay
[Applause]
you guys have it committee report is
adopted
majority of committee on health and
human services and elderly affairs to
which was referred house bill 1455
and act relative to state enforcement of
federal mandate vaccine mandates
consider the same report the same with
the recommendation of bill lada pass
senator mark pearson from the majority
of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate jerry kanerk
from the minority of the committee
thank you mr speaker
it is with trepidation
but also with respect
at the hearing a conflict caused by this
bill was identified but it was never
addressed in the committee process
hb 1455 prohibits the state of new
hampshire and any of its subdivisions
from assisting in the enforcement of any
federal order rule or law
which requires a person to submit proof
of vaccination against covet 19
as a condition of employment
but this
creates a conflict for the department of
health and human services
because dhhs is a state agency and it is
responsible
for confirming that health care
facilities
are in compliance with federal mandates
as part of the accreditation process of
a health care facility
and this includes compliance with the
cms mandate requiring covet 19
vaccination of health care workers
so prohibiting dhhs from doing their
duty of accrediting health care
facilities
that'll have impacts it'll lead to a
loss of accreditation of facilities
that leads to a loss of reimbursement
from cms for medicaid
and for medicare patients and ultimately
for termination from medicare
and medicaid programs and remember
medicaid provides the majority of
funding for our nursing homes
it will also lead to payment loss of
payment from private insurers
the reason is
they don't pay unaccredited facilities
the loss of reimbursements will require
the state of new hampshire
or our counties or both
to backfill hundreds of millions of
dollars in funding to keep our hospitals
and nursing homes open
now in january 13 the u.s supreme court
upheld the cms mandate for the
vaccination of health care workers
they stayed the lower court injunction
and if you read the text of their
decision they make it really really
clear
that they support the cms vaccine
mandate
if it makes it through some appeal
process and comes to them they will
still support it but furthermore there
have been no appeals to that supreme
court decision in the two months that
have elapsed since that time
so it stands
i do not think that the state of new
hampshire
should place itself
and our counties in the position of
needing to backfill hundreds of millions
of dollars of funding to keep our
hospitals and nursing homes open
so i would encourage you to press the
red button to vote no
on hb1455
so another motion can be brought forth
and i would request a division vote and
perhaps also
your
forgiveness
we are down to the last speaker
representative blazik has requested a
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
chair recognizes representative mark
pearson
thank you mr speaker and might i add
thank you mr speaker
the balance of power and responsibility
between the federal government and the
states
has often tilted against that wonderful
balance enshrined in the 10th amendment
in the 19th century some northern states
passed personal liberty laws which made
it illegal
for citizens of their states to help
enforce
the federal fugitive slave act
and in our day some states perhaps
different from us in their political
beliefs
have claimed the right to be
sanctuary states
and thus banned cooperation with federal
authorities regarding illegal immigrants
i've heard this commended yesterday by
members of the party across the aisle
if we agree with them and such states
then and now not so much
exactly on the specific topic but on the
idea of saying no
then the legitimacy of a mandated lack
of cooperation we should understand is
the motivation behind this bill
i know that some other states have
similarly asserted rights on this very
subject matter contained in this
absolutely wonderful brilliantly
and they've not lost federal
reimbursement for medicare or medicaid
and in terms of what the supreme court
might do
in 1997 the supreme court ruled in
prince versus the united states that
congress cannot make the states enforce
the federal brady gun control law which
attempted to require local sheriffs or
police to carry out background checks
i recommend we pass this bill and stand
with other states progressive
conservative and in between so that the
movement to reset the balance between
the federal government and the
individual states can continue to grow
i think we should stand together with
all these other states that are saying
to the federal government
we are proudly american
the motion before us is the majority
report of ought to pass house bill
1455.
this is going to be a roll call vote
the motion before us is the majority
report of auto pass on house bill 1455
the chair recognizes the representative
conurk for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this bill will prohibit the
department of health and human services
from accrediting our health care
facilities
and if i know that that loss of
accreditation will place in jeopardy the
facility revenues from medicare medicaid
and private insurers
and if i know that the loss of revenue
will require the state and the counties
to backfill a couple of hundred million
dollars annually just to keep our
hospitals and nursing homes open
and if i know that it might be a bit of
a stretch
to compare slavery with immunization
would i then please press the red button
to vote otp
to vote no i'm sorry on the otp
no on the otp red button so that another
motion could be brought forth thank you
mr speaker
chair recognizes representative leon for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that the powers of the federal
government are limited to those
delegated by the constitution
and if i know that states have
successfully asserted their right to
determine policy on things ranging from
fugitive slaves to immigration policy to
these very same coveted policies we
discuss here
and if i want to reiterate the statement
that new hampshire will not be
blackmailed
house will be in order
the motion before us is a majority
report about a pass on house bill 1455
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
while members president had an
opportunity to vote
174 voting yay 159 voting the committee
majority of the committee on health and
human services and elderly affairs to
well i've already reading the report
right now so
enact repealing the statute relative to
medical freedom and immunizations having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate as in africa
lay on for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority report
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass president of joe shapiro for the
for what reason does a member rise to
make a motion mr speaker state your
in a mark pearson moves that we table
house bill 1481
representative
blazik has requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
the motion before us is a table
the chair recognizes
representative leon for a parliamentary
inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that by tabling this bill we
will protect the medical freedom and
immunizations law which we passed last
year
and if i know that this law protected
new hampshire from mandating and then
walking back
vaccine mandates like we've seen in
places to our south
would i then press the green button to
protect the fundamental human right to
give informed consent for any medical
procedure
chair recognizes representative shapiro
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that the medical
freedom and immunization act will
exclude
critical public health measures if there
should be another deadly surge of covet
19.
and mr speaker if i know that it is time
to end the partisan bickering and find a
reasonable balance between personal
choice and public health or the common
good
then
would i push the red button so the table
in motion can be defeated and we can
debate this issue
thank you
the motion before us
is to table house bill 1481
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you opposed you'll press the red button
so
representing mclean representative
gordon
it's too late i need a thumb up for a
thumb down
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
175 voting 856 voting a
majority of committee on health and
human services and elderly affairs to
which was referred house bill 14
95 fn and act relative to vaccine
mandates for government contractors been
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment
representative dennis acton for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate president lucy
weber from the minority of the committee
the amendment is 1013h
printed in house record 10a page 66. are
you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it an amendment is adopted
the motion before us now is ought to
pass with amendment
the chair recognizes representative
weber
okay
into the weeds we go
the bill is filed forbid
the state or any of its political
subdivisions so your towns your county
nursing homes all of that stuff
uh from enforcing any federal vaccine
mandates with respect to government
contract people receiving government
contracts
thank you
immediately
when we started listening to this we ran
up to the usual problem
one of the things that the state might
be doing is
the licensing of hospitals and nursing
homes
and they are
contracted with the federal government
to enforce certain federal mandates
because of the centers for medicare and
medicaid
and the majority amendment actually
recognizes this might be a problem and
carved that out as an exception to their
amendment
so that was a plus with the amendment
on the other hand the amendment also
broadened the state's
prohibition from enforcing any mandate
or
seeing any documentation
on any business at all in the state of
new hampshire
the concern that i have with that
is that we already knew
there was a problem in one health care
area with that
and
we on the health and human services
committee do not know what other
conflicts
we are creating with the breadth of this
bill as it was amended
or what is going to come to bite us in
the future
so
i ask that you press the red button
to
defeat the ought to pass with amendment
get us out of what might be
a lot of unintended consequences so
we are down to the last speaker
representative blazik has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
this it is sufficiently seconded this is
going to be a roll call vote members
thank you mr speaker
i think we all know that last fall a lot
of bills were filed because we weren't
sure what this year would bring
this amendment distills down
a bill that was filed to some of the
very core ideas
the fact that the state should not be
requiring businesses to act as their
enforcement arm
this doesn't prohibit businesses from
making their own choice
and those businesses that have different
roles or regulations upon them
probably have a reason to check on their
own so that they can comply with
whatever they believe is in their best
interest
what this bill amendment this bill is
amendment does
is it says that the state
and any subdivision can't require a
business to check for vaccination
except for the childhood immunization
rules
because if we ban that we'd get rid of
child care and we don't want to do that
it also says that we can't ask a
business to check for documentation a
vaccination status
so we don't end up in the situation
where in new york city mcdonald's was
turning away customers from eating
inside the building
and we have a curve out here
we do have a carve out that says that
this shall not apply to state agencies
certifying a medical facility or private
or provider which is subject to a valid
and enforceable medicaid or medicare
condition of participation that imposes
a vaccination requirement
this bill is simple
it makes it so that businesses won't be
the enforcement arm of the state
so i ask that you pass this bill by
motion before us
is to ought to pass as amended on house
bill 1445.
this is a roll call vote members take
the motion before us is the majority
report of auto passes amended on 1445
this is a roll call vote the chair
recognizes representative webber for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that this bill is
folks with government contracts
and that
the
amendment broadened it to include any
business in the state
and if i know that
we already found one problem that was
fixed in amendment
but we don't know what other problems
lurk out there because people didn't
have notice to come and tell us about
them
would i now press the red button so
another motion could be made
thank you mr speaker i recognize the
representative mark peterson for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that overburdening businesses
with being state enforcement agencies
and that a state mandated banning of
individuals seeking to enter commercial
establishments has not worked well at
all
in those states that decreed those
mandates
and if i know that the amendment to this
bill which we just passed has made it
such that we will now be voting only on
commercial facilities and not on medical
ones
would i not now press the green button
to ensure a good balance between freedom
and responsibility
thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is a majority
report
as amended on house bill 1445.
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button of
your opposer press the red button voting
if all members president had an
house will attend to the state of the
vote
179 voting a 153 voting a committee
majority of the committee on judiciary
also be in order
an act relating to reproductive medical
decisions providing that the state shall
not infringe or unduly inconvenience the
right of reproductive medical decisions
have been considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate representative jeanine notter
minority of the committee having
considered the same in being unable to
agree with the majority report with a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass
representative rebecca macbeth for the
for what reason is a member rise
thank you mr speaker i'd like to make a
motion
sage a motion i'd like to table this
bill
that is a proper motion the motion
roll call
roll call has
a role
call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded it is efficiently
the motion before us is the table cacr18
this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative nada
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that this
bill will take two-thirds of those
president voting to pass
and
mr speaker if i also know that we're not
likely to get that so
let's just save some time and press the
jay i recognize representative query for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i believe
reproductive justice meaning that all
people regarding of race class or gender
have the right to make autonomous
reproductive decisions and should have
the resources and support to do so and
if i know that that the vermont house
recently moved to put protections for
reproductive rights into their state
constitution
and with attacks on both the national
and state level we must protect this
human right if i know that the
overwhelming number of new hampshire
constituents regardless of political
party are pro-reproductive freemen
freedom
and deserve to weigh in on this topic
would i go ahead
and vote against the tabling motion
thank you
the motion before us is the table
cacr18 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button of your opposed you press
the red button voting stations are open
[Music]
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
175 voting a 157 voting a
house will be in order
majority of the committee on judiciary
to which was referred house bill 1014 an
act allowing public meetings to be
conducted virtually considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate
president of mark mclean for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment a recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with the
amendment present of alexis simpson for
for what reason does it memorize
to make a motion
stage motion
emotion to table
the motion was to
table house bill
a division has been requested members
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
the motion before us is a table 1014
house bill 1014
chair recognizes representative
thank you mr speaker
if i know that under rare circumstances
our current rsas allow a public body to
permit a member of that body on a rare
exception to participate by electronic
means
and if i also know that the changes
proposed in hb 1014
contain new provisions that would make
the 91a rsas
cumbersome inefficient
and in most cases completely unworkable
in both small and large public bodies
and if i also know that in person
face-to-face meetings
by the public body as well as the
in-person participation by the public
for hundreds of years has been and
should continue to be
the predominant way of conducting the
people's business
would i now press the green button and
support the majority recommendation of
itl thank you mr speaker chair
recognizer
table
chair recognizes representative page for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that hb 1014 will promote
citizen engagement with their local
government officials and therefore
strengthen our representative democracy
by allowing them to participate remotely
in public meetings an incredibly popular
idea among granite staters and if i
further know that this bill protects
local control by simply providing
guidance and not a requirement for a
government body seeking to implement a
remote option
would i then press the red button
and allow for a debate to be to occur
thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is the tabling
motion on house bill 1014
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you oppose you press the red button
so
[Music]
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
175 voting a 155 voting a
house bill
majority of the committee on judiciary
to which was referred house bill 1073 an
act repealing the right to no exemption
for attorney-client work product
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with amendment senate kurt walper for
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee
have been considered the same between
unable to agree with the majority report
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate
representative rebecca macbeth for the
minority of the committee the amendment
is zero six eight nine h printed in
house record 10 a page
10. are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the amendment is adopted the motion
before us now is ought to pass with
amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
the eyes have it and the committee
majority of committee on judiciary to
which was referred house bill 1101 an
act relative to a forfeiture of personal
property considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass senate of mike sylvia
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator douglas
trottier for the minority of the
committee
the motion before us is ought to pass
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
committee on judiciary to which was
referred house bill 1107 an act
establishing a committee to study the
rental or lease of housing to a person
who has pets have been considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolve that isn't expedient
to legislate president of joe alexander
for the committee
j.r recognizes representative horrigan
the house will be in order
for what reason is memorized to make a
motion
state your motion i move to lay hp 1107
on the table
that is a higher priority motion the
motion is to lay house bill 1107 on the
table
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
the eyes have it and house bill 1107 is
house will be in order
committee on judiciary to which was
referred house bill 1133
now prohibiting the termination of a
lease during the sale of real property
we could
consider the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate president
joe alexander for the committee
the motion before us is the
motion of inexpedient to legislate are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
the house will be in order
majority of the committee on judiciary
to which was referred house bill one two
zero zero and act relative to notice of
rent increases in residential rental
property considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate senator michael sylvia for the
majority of the committee
majority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative marjorie smith when
what reason does a member rise
to make a motion mr stage emotion
it is a proper motion the motion to
table has been made for house bill
1200.
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
eyes the eyes have it house bill 1200 is
majority committee on judiciary to which
was referred house bill 1291 an act
prohibiting discrimination against
tenants holding certain vouchers
for purposes of renting dwellings
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate
representative joe alexander from the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass senator cam kenneth lee
committee for what reason does a member
rise
to make a motion mr speaker state your
motion to table
it's a proper motion the motion
are you ready for the question
a division has been requested
roll call has been requested is that
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
okay
the motion before us is the table
chair recognizes representative mclean
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that new hampshire
is hip deep in the middle of a huge
housing crisis
if i know that we need to be encouraging
more landlords to enter into the market
and not placing new burdens that would
push them out of the market
and if i know that hb 1291 would
forcefully drive all landlords into
participating in the federal section 8
housing voucher program whether they
wanted to or not and thus require that
they unwillingly enter into contracts
that they had no say in and if i believe
that that would actually reduce the
housing inventory would i now press the
green button to table this bill thank
you mr speaker
chair recognizes representative marjorie
smith for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
knowing that there are at least a few
bills that are too important
to dismiss
and mr speaker knowing that the section
8 housing program makes it possible
for people who could not otherwise have
access to decent housing
and knowing that for landlords it's a
guarantee
that they're going to be paid
because the money comes not necessarily
from the
the tenant but from the government
would i now
vote no on tabling so this body could
take one small step to help address the
problems of housing in this
state motion before us is the tabling
motion on house bill one two nine one
this is a
roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
[Music]
all members president an opportunity to
vote
179 voting a 148 voting a
majority committee on judiciary to which
was referred house bill 1389 fn
an act establishing a superior court
land use review docket having considered
the same report the same with the
recommendation to be
bill be referred for interim study
senator marjorie smith with a majority
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment a recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
amendment senator mclean from the
minority of the committee
the motion before us is
the committee report referred for
interim study are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it and committee report is
adopted
so
the committee on judiciary to which was
referred house bill 1425 fn
act relative
house will be in order
and act relative to the taking of real
property by eminent domain having
considered the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass senator mark mclean for
the committee
is in a blazik
has requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
so
the motion before us
is ought to pass on house bill 1425 fn
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
representatives
representative ford
president had an opportunity to vote
onion 79 voting a 150 voting a committee
majority of the committee on judiciary
to which was referred house bill 1477 fn
knack prohibiting abortions after
detection of fetal heartbeat considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpensive to legislate senator diane
langley for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
from senator mark mclean from the
the chair recognizes
mr speaker i'm here to speak in
opposition to the committee
recommendation of itl on hb 1477.
this is a bill that would ban abortion
after the detection of a fetal heartbeat
as defined as cardiac activity or the
steady repetitive rhythmic contraction
one of the things that the roe versus
wade decision sought to explore
was where life begins and they went and
they looked at the many religious
beliefs practiced throughout the country
and what they found was there was no
consistency there was a great amount of
disagreement within those beliefs and so
you couldn't just settle in on one faith
so putting religion aside
they also went and they found that
doctors had many varying views as well
but one area of agreement however was
that most doctors tended to believe that
life began at some time
before
birth
and it's for that reason that the royal
court held
that the right to abortion was not
absolute
and it tried to balance a woman's right
to privacy and the fetus's right to
exist
hb 1477 simply looks at all the
scientific
information that was not available to
the royal court 50 years ago and it
asked the question
does life begin earlier than the row
court thought and does that enhance the
right of the fetus to maintain his or
her life
we now know a lot more about the
complexities of fetal development than
the royal court could ever imagine
and in light of that expanded knowledge
the minority felt that while the rights
of the mother are undiminished
the rights of the fetus are elevated to
a point where its status must be
reconsidered
at the stage of life defined in this
bill where a fetal heartbeat has been
detected the minority felt that the
development had advanced to the point
where the fetus's status as an
individual human entity has been
established and we therefore ask you
overturn the itr motion so the motion of
otp can be brought forward thank you mr
speaker does the member yield the
questions
no thank you member does not yield
thank you
house bill 1477
house bill 1477 as written
is a near total ban on abortion within
the state of new hampshire were this
bill to pass it would essentially
end access to abortion in new hampshire
as it is being on abortion at around six
weeks
only two weeks after a woman's first
missed menses
a time when many women have not even do
not even know that she's pregnant to put
it in another way
this bill could take away a woman's
right to make her own medical decision
before she even knows that she has a
decision to make
house bill 1477
is wildly out of step with the granite
state values
abortion bans are deeply held
popular view in new hampshire
instead we've had a lot we've had a long
bipartisan tradition of supporting
reproductive freedom
the vast majority of granite staters
believe that personal
private medical decisions should be
between the individual and the doctor
not the individual and politicians
we can all agree
grant staters deserve access to the best
medical care available
without shame or government interference
if this bill were to pass that would no
longer be the case for a woman seeking
abortion care
passage of this bill
would force a woman who cannot who can
afford an abortion to leave and go out
of state
for those women who could not travel out
of state due to lack of finances or
transportation
she would be forced to remain pregnant
against her will
further this would rob her of the trust
the guidance and the expertise of the
competent medical professional she had
selected
when making with her partner if she cho
so chooses one of the most intimate and
personal of life's decisions
instead instead the decision would
follow a predetermined path that had
finally
we don't have to imagine the impact of
this abortion bill we can simply look to
the state of texas and see the havoc
that the abortion bills that have been
created in texas have placed on the
mental health the health care system
thank you
please push the green button
to itl this bill does the member yield
to questions
for what reason does a member rise
um
to make a motion mr speaker state your
motion
and i'd like to speak to my motion my
motion is to table on house bill 14 77
i can't you can do it
i'd like to give api okay
the motion before us is to table house
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
efficiently seconded this will be a roll
so
the house will be in order
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1477.
the chair recognizes representative
marjorie smith for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
knew
that my
very distinguished
colleague
from stratford county would find a way
to pack the house again and bring
everybody in from the anteroom
and if i knew
that
while he was able to do that there are
many members
of this body who at 8 30 in the evening
were not able to be here and register
their position
on this very important vote
would i now vote
house bill
1477 with the expectation
that in the very near future perhaps as
soon as tomorrow
we would be able to move to take this
bill off the table and have everyone in
the new hampshire house be able to vote
yes or no
thank you mr speaker
the motion before us
is the tabling motion on house bill
1477.
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
so
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
185 voting 843 voting nay
majority of the committee on judiciary
to which was referred house bill 1490 fn
act relative to equal access to places
of public accommodation regardless of
vaccine status we consider the same
report the same with the recommendation
the bill ought to pass senator kurt
walper for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate is in a marked
page for the minority of the committee
chair recognizes
represent
thank you mr speaker
i rise today in opposition to the
recommendation that hb 1490 ought to
pass
under our state's anti-discrimination
statutes this bill would create a new
but undefined category of protected
class vaccination status
in addition the bill would prohibit
places of public accommodation including
health care providers
from denying entrance to someone based
on their vaccination status and also
prohibit them from requiring a person to
use a medical device another undefined
term in the bill
as we contemplate creating another
category of a protected class
it's worth considering the other
enumerated classes already protected
against discrimination to which
vaccination status would be
added existing law prohibits
discrimination and public accommodations
based on categories such as age
sex
gender identity or race
these are protected because
unfortunately they have faced a long
history of discrimination in exercising
the civil rights
in this light adding vaccination status
as a protected class seems a historical
and misplaced
but beyond that it's worth thinking
about the purpose and context of the
state's anti-discrimination statute
rsa 354-a where this bill would rest if
it became law
was enacted under the state's police
powers to protect the welfare and health
of our citizens
yet this bill if enacted
would threaten public health rather than
protect it
for example this bill would be
enforceable against health care
providers creating a scenario whereby
these providers could not require
vaccines
or even masks perhaps
thus potentially exposing employees and
patients to lethal
but preventable diseases such as covet
19.
indeed at committee healthcare providers
testified that the threat that this bill
represents to their ability to
effectively protect
their employees and patients health and
safety
surely such a result is at cross
purposes with the legislative intent of
rsa rsa354a to protect
the public safety and welfare of our
citizens
and finally this bill suffers from
significant definitional shortcomings
both vaccination status
and medical devices the operative terms
of the bill are undefined
the department of justice noted that
this vagueness would lead to an increase
in complaints under the law
diverting scarce resources to resolving
the meaning and application of these
terms
i urge you to oppose the committee's
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if there's anything we've
heard about
today and for the last couple of years
and can i be forced to get it
in masks and do i have to wear them
mr speaker we looked at this
might go ahead get any other advice or
we had other bills that dealt with the
same
topic and you've heard a lot about it
today about rights about to be
vaccinated and conscious rights and all
of that
we
chose
to bring this one bill forward
dealing narrowly with public
accommodation
because we hear a testimony mr speaker
of people who couldn't go buy their
groceries
because they couldn't wear masks for
medical reasons the medical device i
spent quite a bit of time trying to
figure out what kind of medical devices
could apply
to and the mask was the only one i could
come up with
you can have it all right so so it
applies to mass and applies to
vaccination status
and we just believe that vaccination
status is
a part of your personal privacy a part
of your medical privacy and you should
not have to disclose that
to use public accommodations whether
it's a bus
or anything else
so for that reason mr speaker i
recommend we pass house bill
1490.
roll call has been requested by
representative silber is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call vote
so
members take your seats this is a roll
guys
the motion before us is the majority
report of auto pass and house bill 1490.
the chair recognizes representative
thank you thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know adding vaccination
status to new hampshire law recognizing
vaccine status as a protected class
is an overreach and a questionable
precedent and if i also know defining
vaccine status as a protected class
under the civil rights act would make it
impossible for health officials
to monitor disease outbreaks and finally
mr speaker if i know
adding vaccination status to
anti-discrimination legislation would
limit the tools
and data available to the state's public
health efforts in protecting the state
excuse me would i now vote no on the
committee report of ought to pass thank
you
chair recognizes representative sylvia
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that discrimination of any
kind
is
a horrible
thing
if i know that your vaccination status
is
a piece of your private information
and further mr speaker if i know that
people should be poking around
and trying to pry your private
personal health information from you
what i then press
the motion before us is the majority
on house bill 1490 this is a roll call
vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
representative
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
161 voting a 170 voting a
representative smith
moves
in expedient to legislate yes you put
the question before us the motion before
us is
the minority report have been expedient
to legislator house bill 1490 are you
ready for the question
representative el disarro requests a
it is not sufficiently seconded this
the motion before us is a minority
reporter in expedient to legislate on
house bill 1490 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
if all members president had an
committee on judiciary to which was
referred house bill 1519 fn an act
defining religious
belief and protecting it from
discrimination having considered the
same report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate senator alexis simpson for
the for the committee
the the emotion before us is the
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it committed report is
adopted
majority on
the committee on judiciary to which was
referred house bill 1625
next repealing the prohibition on
entering or remaining on a public way or
sidewalk adjacent to a reproductive
health care facility considered the same
report the same
with the fallen resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate is in a
marked page for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative mark mclean from the
minority of the committee
chair recognizes the representative
mclean
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
the minority of the house judiciary
committee felt that hb 1625
a bill repealing the new hampshire law
prohibiting people from being present on
a public way adjacent to a reproductive
health facility is long overdue
the new hampshire buffer zone law was
enacted in 2014
and it's modeled after and largely
similar to
a massachusetts law that the u.s supreme
court struck down in june of that year
now the supreme court
was unanimous in its ruling that
extending a buffer zone from clinic
entrances was a violation of the first
amendment rights of those that sought to
protest or offer counseling outside
facilities
chief justice roberts in his opinion
stated that authorities have many less
intrusive ways to deal with problems
outside the clinics
and the committee heard testimony that
existing criminal threatening laws are
more than adequate to deal with most
problems that arise
given the constitutional issues plaguing
this law
one might ask the question
why hasn't it been struck down like the
massachusetts law was struck down and
the reason is simple
after more than seven years no abortion
clinic or reproductive health facility
in new hampshire has ever
implemented its provisions ever
as a result
no one has ever had standing to take it
to court so let that sink in for a
little bit
supporters of the bill repeatedly
stressed its urgent need as a tool to
keep clinics safe
and yet
having won the day
they never implemented the law that they
had fought so hard for
every effort
at appeal
has led to a great outcry that women and
clinic staff
would be subjected to increased danger
if a repeal were successful well guess
what
the repeals were never successful they
were always unsuccessful and still
the provisions of the law were never
implemented so let me ask you this
how can removing something that has
never been implemented after seven years
in this legislature we should not seek
to burden the state with an
unconstitutional law that looks to
inhibit the rights of our people to
peacefully
and prayerfully express themselves
this is especially the case
when the law in question by its ongoing
inaction turns a blind eye to the very
people it purports to serve
it's time for repeal and i hope you will
join with me in overturning the itl
motion on this bill so the motion of
ought to pass can be brought forward
representative notter has requested a
roll call we're down to the last speaker
is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this is
going to be a roll call vote members
i rise today to speak in favor
of the bipartisan majority
recommendation of the judiciary that hb
1625 is inexpedient to legislate
as we've heard hb 1625 would repeal the
state's current patient safety zone law
which provides for a safety zone around
reproductive health care facilities
the bill is premised on the notion that
our current law is unconstitutional
because the u.s supreme court struck
down a restrictive massachusetts law
there are a few preliminary points to
keep in mind that on their own make this
bill an expedient to legislate to begin
with
the question of constitutionality of our
current law is one for the courts not
this legislature to resolve
in addition
it is important to note that placing
reasonable restrictions on first
amendment rights in public spaces is
nothing new in this state and many
others
for example we have similar protective
zones around entrances and polling
places that permit voters to enter the
voting booth without interference
while also successfully preserving
others first amendment rights
but the fatal flaw in this bill is its
reliance on the erroneous premise that
because the u.s supreme court struck
down massachusetts buffer zone law in a
case known as mccullen our law is also
unconstitutional
but this misreads mccullen the
massachusetts case as dictating that new
hampshire must also repeal its law
the real lesson from the mccullen
massachusetts case is that there is no
bright line supreme court
test applicable to every state safety
zone law
each state statute must be evaluated on
its own
and different facts lead to different
outcomes
for example the supreme court has upheld
a colorado safety zone law and in
january of 2021
the court declined to hear a challenge
to a pittsburgh ordinance providing a
15-foot safety zone around reproductive
facilities letting that ordinance stand
but importantly the bipartisan
co-sponsors of our current new hampshire
patient safety zone law carefully
crafted our law
with attention to the issues raised in
mccullen to which they had the benefit
of hindsight review
as a result new hampshire's current law
which this bill would repeal does not
create a mccullen problem but rather
avoids one
mccullen the supreme court found
massachusetts approach too rigid and
extreme
that law mandated a 35-foot zone at
every facility across that state
and imposed both civil and criminal
penalties including a jail term
new hampshire intentionally did not
follow the massachusetts path when it
enacted our current safety zone law to
avoid any constitutional problems
unlike the massachusetts statute our
current law does not mandate that every
reproductive health care facility
establish a safety zone
instead it enables
their creation depending on the unique
location and circumstances
our current law does not require a fixed
specified zone at every state it permits
establishment of one up to 25 feet
and unlike massachusetts our law imposes
only civil penalties not criminal
in some our law embeds the elasticity
that the supreme court found lacking in
massachusetts law
in 2016 our attorney general
successfully defended our patient safety
zone law in ready versus foster where
the federal district court of new
hampshire concluded that the
constitutionality of our law could only
be rendered on the facts at the time of
implementation when and if a health
facility uses a safety zone
put another way not only it is is it not
appropriate for this branch to determine
the constitutionality of our current law
but it's also premature to do so
finally it's not clear what problem this
bill would fix
indeed we heard committee testimony of
people successfully engaging
with women entering reproductive
facilities suggesting that the current
statutory framework strikes the right
balance between competing rights and
should not be disturbed
i respectfully ask that you uphold the
bipartisan recommendation of the
for what reason does the member rise
i rise to make a motion mr speaker state
your motion
i would move to table house bill 16
25.
that is a proper motion
the motion before us is to table house
we don't have a we don't have any
representative nader has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
so
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1625.
this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative marjorie smith
thank you mr speaker i'm honored to go
first i expect always to follow
um mr speaker
if i know that consistency is the
bugaboo of small minds but nevertheless
believe that the same argument that i
made 35 minutes ago is even more true
now
in that this issue is so important to so
many people
that we should not be voting on it at
905 in the evening but perhaps at say 9
30 in the morning
would i now vote yes to table
thank you
chair recognize the representative
naughter for parliamentary inquiry
[Music]
thank you mr speaker
if i know that our buffer zone law is
transparently unconstitutional and has
never been enforced
and if i also know that it serves no
purpose except to chill and deter lawful
speech that supporters of the law find
defensive
and mr speaker if i know that the new
hampshire constitution says that free
speech is essential to the security of
freedom
would i then preserve the freedom of
speech and press the red button to
oppose this tabling motion thank you
motion before us
on house bill
is the table
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed or press
the red button voting stations are open
well
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
160 voting a 170 voting a the tabling
the motion before us now is the majority
report have been expedient to legislate
on health bill 1625
this is a roll call vote
the motion before us is the majority
report of inexpedient to legislate on
house bill 1625
the chair recognizes representative nada
thank you mr speaker if i know that i
just gave a parliamentary inquiry and
that it applies to this motion as well
would i then vote red on the itl thank
you
chair recognizes representative marjorie
smith for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if efforts to make sure that as many
people as possible could vote have
failed
would i now recognize the obligation of
those here
to support
the bipartisan vote
of the judiciary committee to itl
1625.
the motion before us is majority report
of inexpensive to legislate on house
bill 1625 this is a roll call vote
you're in favor you press the green
button if you're opposed you press the
red button voting stations are open for
so
[Music]
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
162 voting a 168 voting a
the itl motion fails
representative notter moves ought to
pass
who requested a roll call
representative edwards requested a roll
call i guess that's sufficiently
seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
the motion before us is ought to pass on
house bill 1625
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
so
representatives
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
168 voting yay 162 voting a minority
just
majority of the committee on judiciary
to which was a house will be in order
to which was referred 1673 fn
act relative to women's health privacy
and repealing
the fetal health protection act having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment senator marjorie
the minority of the committee having
considered the same will be unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following amendment a recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
amendment senator kurt walper for the
minority of the committee
the debate is going to be on the
majority committee report
on the amendment
0730h
i know it's been a very long day
and this is a topic that um
garners a lot of attention
and uh is difficult in a lot of ways for
a lot of people so i'll try to keep my
comments brief this evening as brief as
possible
and there are a lot of things that i
would really like to speak about this
evening but what i would like to do
primarily is just remind us of what the
fetal life protection act does
and what this amendment does to the
fetal life protection act
the fetal life protection act
outlaws
the killing of a child after six months
gestation to nine months gestation in
for the first time in the state of new
hampshire's history
it gives equal protection
under the law to those people
so for the first time in history people
who are that old
can cannot be killed any more than any
and that puts us in a very unique
because for the first time in the state
of new hampshire's history this body has
the power to remove equal protection
under the law from some of our citizens
so the next time
the next time that
an abortionist
legally approaches
a child between the gestational age of
and stabs that child through the heart
and inserts poison into its veins
until the heart seizes up
when we can't hear its silent scream of
agony
we approved it not only did we approve
this amendment basically guts any
protection
that any child in this age range will
will have
it doesn't protect any of them
it kind of dresses it up with some
[Music]
some different language
fetal anomalies not compatible with life
and a generalized health exception
it strips all of the criminal and civil
penalties
out of the bill essentially rendering it
i've had a lot of conversations with
people around this chamber and the
number one thing that i've heard
is that we don't believe that children
and there's something that i would like
to straighten out about this particular
point in pregnancy
i'd like to to make it understood that
every abortion at this point the child
the child will have to be born
and when that process
of abortion is completed when that child
is killed
and the mother is induced and the child
is delivered and that child
is held in the hands of the abortionist
that child is no longer in the mother's
womb
is a complete human being
and it's a dead human being
it has a hole in the heart
its
veins are full of poison
under any other circumstances we would
call that murder
but for some reason we have this
complete unscientific notion that the
child who is in the womb two minutes
before
and the child who's outside the woman
after are completely different and if i
could just if somebody could get up here
and explain that to me i'd be
because otherwise what we're saying is
that
we believe that it's completely
acceptable
to either
kill the child have it born dead or even
worse in some cases completely
dismembered
body part by body part this is this is
this is what the fetal life protection
act outlaws
leg detached head detached body
completely torn apart and when we're
done there's a pile of human body parts
on the table
i i would question the member on his
language
oh i'm sorry i didn't realize i'm sorry
i'm new at this
ladies and gentlemen of the general
court
i urge you
to turn down the committee amendment on
this bill so the better
the chair recognizes
truth
does still carry
some weight
is
a coming together
of disparate views
how did we get into this situation in
we got into this situation because
although every one of us knows
that the finance committee
never
never gets involved in policy
and only deals with budget matters you
all do know that
i know it from my years as chair of
finance committee never did we get
involved with anything that would be
policy
except when we wanted to
we all know
because it has been stated publicly
by people who were making the decisions
that the reason
that certain sections were put in house
bill 2
that's the budget trailer bill that is
supposed to support things relating to
money
the things that were irrelevant to money
because there's no public dollar that
goes into
there's no public dollar that goes into
funding abortions in this state
nonetheless
decisions were made to include language
having to do with state policy
affecting
okay
that was done by the finance committee
because it never gets involved with
policy and this body
in order to pass the budget
agreed
and the governor
who stated as clearly as he possibly
could that he didn't like some of the
language
but nonetheless because it was in the
budget he had to sign it
signed it
fine that's what happens in a democratic
small d democratic form of government
where we have republicans and democrats
and independents we have people with
different views
on different subjects and we accommodate
as much as we can
that being the case
we then
looked at what the language was and what
the language accomplished and didn't
accomplish
as a
result and after a lot of discussion
the judiciary committee came up with an
affecting
women's health as it relates to the
fetal
protection act so named
in the budget
one part
was to take language
developed by one of our colleagues who
effective
advocates
[Music]
for
what he views as fetal protection we
took language exact language that he
came up with
and it's language that you can see in
both the majority amendment and the
minority amendment
that
the judiciary committee came up with we
took language
that acknowledged
the 24
week
limit on
in which under ordinary circumstances
abortions could be performed in the
state
we also
took the language that was
somewhat unclear
having to do
with
with certain tests about
to which a pregnant woman would be
subjected
and we said that would only happen not
at the beginning of a pregnancy but if
there was some question as to whether we
were at the 24
week deadline or not this was a minority
amendment and the majority amendment it
is exactly the same language
we said
and you can read about it in in the
report in the calendar
we said
okay first
that the gestational age of 24 weeks as
i said was we would accept as a limit
we said
except
in cases where there are fetal anomalies
that are inconsistent with life
not field anomalies that might be
anomalies but are not going to interfere
with life only those that were
consistent with life
and we said talked about the ultrasound
test
we then eliminated
the criminal and civil penalties
that were in
the fetal protection act
in this state medical care
in
most states but certainly in this state
medical care in the reproductive health
or gynecology field
including abortion
is provided by medical professionals who
despite what some people might say are
licensed by the new hampshire board of
medicine and the new hampshire board of
nursing
these boards oversee the education
background training of every doctor
nurse and practitioner and physician
assistant in new hampshire
and in addition to the state
requirements um we also know that
these providers are insured and the
insurers maintain certain standards
we eliminated the civil and criminal
penalties here because if in fact
someone were to act
in violation of the law
they would be held accountable by the
appropriate
bodies
to have this language free-floating
meant
that we that there were many people who
would say
we're not going to come to new hampshire
to practice medicine we're not going to
take the chance
that some idle
okay so we did a change in credentialing
we did a change
in um
ultrasound and we acknowledged
the you know that
fetal anomalies and the health of
life and health of the mother are
important
there were other things we didn't change
for example we didn't address the
language of rape and incest there were
other changes that we didn't make why
because in the house judiciary committee
we work together we try to find common
ground we try to balance the competing
demands of disparate views and we did a
good job
now
at this time now it's 9 30
and
people continue to leave
mr speaker i'm going to stop for a
moment only because my mother told me
never to speak while others were
speaking
i don't know thank you i don't know how
many times i've asked today
for the chamber
to be quiet
and i'm addressing both sides again
that
neither side
is complying with the simple request to
so hopefully this will be my last
request for the day
let the members speak if you need to
have a conversation take it out into the
annie room
thank you may continue
thank you mr speaker i'm tired and i
assume everyone here is tired
i made a suggestion a while ago
that we put off this discussion
until tomorrow
that did not seem to be
the will
of the body and so we're proceeding now
but there is no
earthly reason
why a majority of this body would not
recognize
that
this bill as amended by a majority of
honors and reflects the feelings of
those with disparate views
but nonetheless continues the long
tradition we have had in this state
of
of respecting women's privacy and the
right for a woman
to make a decision having to do
with her body
without 400 members of the legislature
trying to find their way
into the doctor's office i ask you to
think about it
and to think about the implications to
remember that not one public dollar
in this state actually in any state not
one public dollar goes to
pay for
abortion in those cases when abortion is
legal
that
to interfere
with our long tradition is not going to
cause abortion to disappear
we have always had abortion
what will happen if we
do not pass this legislation in this way
is the possibility
the member will suspend
mr speaker i believe that
the representative is wandering off
subject quite a bit and my understanding
we're
discussing the amendment to the bill
member may continue
thank you mr speaker and i respect the
concerns of the members i hope they're
paying attention to realize that i have
in fact been addressing
the three major changes that the
amendment to the bill
brings into play
and recognize that with this amendment
and this bill
we will have a logical
careful
governing of
of abortion as it is appropriate in this
state
and that we will make sure
that we are not going to do here what
has happened in other states
where abortion continues but without the
safe
requirements
[Music]
when you can get a legal abortion thank
the motion before the before us is the
majority amendment
representative notter has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is officially seconded this will be a
roll call vote
sorry
the motion before us is the majority
amendment
on house bill 1673
this is a roll call vote the chair
recognizes representative notter for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that this
amendment makes a mockery of the fetal
life protection act by removing all
penalties for late term abortions
because there is no way to hold any
violator accountable
and if i know that this majority
amendment adds on an open-ended
exception that makes the law a
meaningless joke
and mr speaker if i know that my
colleagues who support abortion up to
birth
should look the people of new hampshire
in the eye and be honest about what they
are doing instead of concealing their
actions with an underhanded gutting bill
would i then press the red button thank
you
we're on
our second to last bill
let's see if we can get through this in
chair recognizes representative
if i know that the impact of our newly
enacted abortion law
is being felt right now most
significantly by families in extremely
complex circumstances
who have learned of a fatal fetal
diagnosis late in their pregnancy
and if i know that this legislative body
earlier today
passed a bill allowing for health care
professionals to make decisions based on
their own conscience
and if i know that the original
ultrasound provision in law is unclear
and we need to clarify it
would i now press the green button to
vote with the bipartisan majority of the
judiciary committee and pass this
amendment
the motion before the house is on the
majority amendment
this is a roll call vote
if you are in favor you will press the
green button if you're opposed you will
press the red button
[Music]
ball members president had an
opportunity to vote
163 voting a 165 voting a the amendment
fails
the jail recognizes representative simon
for
mr speaker i move the adoption of the
minority amendment zero six eight eight
h
thank you mr speaker
this amendment is the amendment that we
have seen frequently uh throughout this
term
it addresses the lack of clarity in the
ultrasound requirement that led
providers to believe that they had to
perform ultrasounds uh
all the way up at the beginning of
pregnancy with transvaginal ultrasounds
that's where that whole conflict came
from that was never the intention
of
the writers of the bill
and this
amendment clarifies that i would just
like to point out that
both sides really do agree on the need
for this bill for this amendment
and we are running out of time to get it
into
one of our bills to be sent over to the
other body so i'd really urge everybody
to adopt this amendment at this point so
that we can send it to the other house
question before us is the minority
amendment zero six eight eight h printed
chair recognizes representative smith
marjorie smith
thank you very much mr speaker this
amendment is an example of what happens
when people of disparate views work
together
i think that the bill as it came to you
was a fine bill
by two votes
[Music]
this body chose not to accept that
nonetheless i would say to you that the
minority amendment
which was in using the exact same
language in the majority amendment
is a good amendment
we it to be added to the bill because
while it doesn't do everything that it
should do it does at least clarify what
had been a very confusing issue
having to do
with
ultrasound use
[Music]
for women who are pregnant therefore i
ask you
the motion before us right now is the
simon amendment
zero six eight eight h
are you ready for the question all those
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
the simon amendment is adopted
the motion before us now
is ought to pass
do we want to go just the vote
the motion before us is ought to pass as
amended on house bill 1673.
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
majority of the committee on judiciary
to which was referred house bill 1674
act relative to reproductive rights
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate senator kurt walper from the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority a report with
a recommendation that the bill ought to
pass present if alexis simpson from the
minority of the committee
chair recognizes representative simpson
speak against the committee reporter
speaker
for what reason to member rise um for a
motion
state your motion i move hb 1674 um lay
that is a high priority motion the
motion before us is to lay house bill
1674 on the table
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
[Applause]
she can't she can't come in
members need to be in your seats this is
there is no pis this is the very
the motion is the table house bill
six seven four
this is again a clarification of the
vote if you're in favor you will press
the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
so
representative silver representative
perez
all members president an opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
306 voting a 19 voting a committee
tabling motion
chair recognizes a remember from auburn
representative osborne for a third
thank you
they resolved that the house now
adjourned from the early session that
the business of the late session be in
order at the present time that the
reading of bills be by title only and
resolutions by caption only and that all
bills ordered a third reading be read a
third time by this resolution and that
all titles of bills be the same as
adopted and that they be passed at the
present time and when the house adjourns
today at me to meet
the question is on the third weekd
motion are you ready for the question
all those in favor say hi
those opposed nay the eyes have it the
motion is adopted chair recognizes the
clerk
there are sandwiches available out back
leftovers feel free to take one on your
ride home there are binax now tests in
your mailboxes for tomorrow please feel
free to take them with you thank you
please take your trash out of the
chamber
[Music]
you